hey guys pete here
let's talk about the fifth episode of
better call saul's final season 605
marks the return of lalo
we got some charm and menace from south
of the border and who knew but he has a
very serviceable american accent that he
can draw on when he needs it
last week we had a lot of interesting
stuff dealing with identity and
appearances and how the characters saw
themselves
this week there was a continuation of
all the paranoia
and also a lot of plans being made
with people anticipating their
opponent's next move
some some some some stuff going on with
that and i mentioned in my recap that
this episode felt uh it felt a little
flat for me in some areas
it wasn't my favorite of the season
part of that was i was pretty sure that
lalo was in germany
that wasn't a big surprise
i had been talking about that
either directly or alluding to it since
the first week after i read one of the
peter gould uh interviews
so there was really no surprise and i'm
not sure how much of that
you know took away from my experience
you know my enjoyment
and so i wanted to see what some other
people thought
um i have my guests here we all have
differing opinions on this episode so
that should make it interesting and why
don't we do our introductions and you
can give us your overall take on the
episode and then i'll come back and
respond to those
um we do have a first time guest today
but gil why don't you go first
sounds good i'm gill from the one take
youtube channel or i'm also one half of
the sawcast podcast
and uh the episode actually worked
really well for me
i didn't know or have any inkling that
lalo was in germany
so i think that helped there was some
mystery for me but even putting that
aside all of the jimmy kim howard stuff
also worked really well for me i found
the episode similar in tone to last week
in the sense that there were a lot of
laughs at least for me
but there was also a constant sense of
foreboding i feel like the entire series
has kind of had a dark cloud over it
because we know where it ends for saul
and we know it's not a good place
but as that's starting to take more
specific shape we're waiting for what's
going to happen with howard what's going
to happen with lalo both of those are
kind of ticking time bombs that we
assume are going to somehow be a
stepping stone into breaking bad into
kim and jimmy's ultimate fates
so
i have been feeling a sort of constant
dread and stress as we get closer and
closer to those bombs going off and i
think we see a few significant moments
of of approaching you know d-day
howard finds out that jimmy and kim are
plotting against him we see that lalo is
kind of circling that proof he's looking
for so as we get closer i'm really
feeling it now where i think there's
some subjectivity in how much you'll
enjoy these episodes
we have to be patient as we wait for
those things to happen and in the
meantime the two things that are
allowing me to be patient are one
visually the show has been a ton of fun
even just the cold open to this episode
i thought was sort of a masterfully done
visual
sequence where it was fun to watch it
was mysterious and at the same time it
acted as almost a memorial to the werner
character
it's also been funny the last couple of
episodes when howard's uh at the
sandpiper meeting and cliff is watching
him so nervously i kind of couldn't stop
laughing any time those two characters
were on screen together and the last
thing i'll mention it that's keeping me
kind of interested while we play the
waiting game
is
i feel like these characters are as they
approach the end we're getting moments
of them kind of taking stock looking
back on the path that got them here
uh
you know for example i think jimmy
mentioning the the nuns back in cicero i
think that gives us a little window into
where his mind is at it has to be very
subtle because these characters are not
the type to openly discuss what they're
thinking and what they're feeling so
it's all going to come out in very
subtle ways but i think we're seeing
these characters reckon with themselves
we're seeing what other people think of
these characters like jimmy at the
courthouse last week like howard so
clearly looking down on jimmy this
episode so all of that stuff is keeping
me interested while i wait for those
bombs to go off and even when i'm
laughing i feel very uncomfortable as we
get closer and closer to that so i was a
fan of the episode
and uh still very curious to see where
things go
all right and so
you can go ahead and uh introduce
yourself chase
hey guys q here so i'm from the channel
the vivid kiwi but my name is also chase
you can call me whatever you like thanks
so much for having me on the stream pete
i'm excited to get into episode 605 and
share how i feel about it so just to
quickly summarize my opinions before we
go in depth i really enjoyed this
episode a lot more than 604 i was on the
edge of my seat the whole time i loved
the hamlin vs goodman fight it was great
to finally see that from the trailers
the cliff and howard confrontation was
satisfying i was also waiting for that
for a few episodes saul howard saw
hiring francesca was great glad to see
her return finally and the hollow
situation well it just had me on the
edge of my seat my heart was racing if i
had to rank this on a tier list which i
will for my episode review spoilers for
that i'd give this episode just a strong
age here
fair enough
um i just before i come back to that i
just wanted to thank mike camparil
for the 20 super chat he says great live
stream pete
a powerhouse of the most insightful
commentators on bcs thank you so much
and keep up the great work
and thank you for that we really
appreciate it and it's a great uh great
to have everybody here today
one of the reasons i decided to to bring
kiwi on this week was because he sent me
a really enthusiastic
message about the episode and um
i was sitting there i was i was just
getting ready to write my script for the
for my recap and i was just thinking
like
i'm not sure where this i think this
might be the my least favorite and so i
thought that was a good you know entry
point because we had been talking about
you know
getting together and talking about bcs
and you know there's schedules and
everything else to think about but i
thought this was a good time because you
know we have a little bit of a differing
opinion
and you know i think that
from you know to say that
i thought it was the worst of the season
that's a little bit different than you
know it was a bet it was bad television
or i didn't enjoy it there was a lot
that i did enjoy and you know we'll be
touching on those things
but i think one of the things that i
thought about whenever i was writing my
you know when i was putting my recap
together was
there's this that we're we're behind the
characters they're keeping us behind the
characters and we don't know
what they're planning and because this
you know this show is
it makes them so complicated and so hard
to read at times there's there's a
there's a there's a distance between us
and and you know where they're at so
i thought that um
you know that that's
that can be uncomfortable like if you
think about the beginning of season four
when jimmy's doing all this really weird
stuff and you don't understand why he's
doing it and it turns out that he
doesn't understand why he's doing it
either i think here like what you're
saying gil it does you know this is a
show that we know for sure rewards
patience you know this isn't this i'm
not confused on that i'm not worried
that oh my god they're gonna uh
you know they're gonna they're gonna
crash the plane into the side of the
mountain or whatever i just think that
uh it's a little bit uncomfortable the
place that they have us in as far as not
really knowing what's going on with
these people um
i like what you mentioned there about
the nuns too about them thinking about
their past
the cold open was you know it was really
fantastic i i didn't know what to expect
but because like i said you know before
episode three we're trained to know that
if we see something there it's going to
be important and they're going to tell
us the story so i kind of think that
we're in that same position in the sea
in the season right like
we know all this stuff is going to be
important we know there's going to be a
payoff and it's going to be like okay
now i understand
but i i just felt like this episode
dragged at a couple of points so
i think unless you have anything that
you want to to add there either one of
you
we can just jump right in and kind of go
through what happened as soon as we look
at these uh super chats did you want to
add anything else
oh no i'm good to just get right into
the nitty and gritty of it
same here
okay so what do we got here we have
matt polikin
499 of all the lawyers that have been on
the show who would you pick to represent
you
i i chuck mcgill um if he was
i don't really can't really say i would
want to hang out with him all that much
but
he can definitely litigate what about
you guys
i'd have to go with
i would say kim wexler
but
kim wexler that's that's letting her
giselle side out because i if someone's
representing me i want them to be
willing to do whatever it takes
including a fake letter writing campaign
from uh kushada the way they got um yeah
hula off so uh you know i was gonna say
jimmy but i think ultimately if you're
willing to take your gloves off and do
whatever it takes kim is ultimately the
strategist that can can think ahead even
further than jimmy mcgill
so you know
i was i was originally thinking about
choosing howard but we haven't really
actually seen him do much you know
lawyering in in the courtroom in this
show he's usually outside of the
courtroom at hhm or something like that
um
i mean
i i just feel like i'd have to choose
saul goodman just because i love his his
wacky antics like in season five how he
he uh got someone on the stand to
mistake who the witness was and and i i
would just love to see some sort of
scheme like that happen in person
yeah i think jimmy would be the most fun
to work with i think kim in in chuck's
you know now that chuck is no longer
around i think kim would probably be
the most solid option i think what
you're saying there about howard is true
and we're going to touch on that i think
a little bit later because
we do see what he's good at in this
episode we see a fantastic example of it
and and yeah i don't think the courtroom
is really where where he excels so i i
would uh i would i wouldn't if i needed
him to
hype me up or you know
get interest in whatever i was doing i
would definitely think about bringing
him on board
and we have one other one
he's quite he's quite the salesman
that's for sure seems like seems like
jimmy's not the only person that's good
with elders
yeah for sure
and we have another one here thank you
for the 499 sachin paul
do you think the show is getting a bit
out of hand with cold opens and montages
some of them make no sense and exist
just for the sake of it
um
no not for me
do either of you guys have a problem
with with the the cold opens
or the
montages
uh for me uh go ahead chase
oh
i mean sometimes it can get a little bit
self-indulgent and um sometimes it can
just be you know you don't really
understand what's going on at first but
by the time you get to the end of the
episode suddenly it all makes sense um i
do kind of like moments like that
especially since i do usually re-watch
the episode immediately after seeing it
for the first time and go through it in
depth while doing all my videos so i do
kind of appreciate what they're going
with there but yeah sometimes it can be
just a little bit self-indulgent
especially with the cinematography you
know even though it is really good um i
don't really think it's a waste of time
or anything like that i and i love the
song choices too for the show like i got
a whole playlist of better call saul
songs um i jam out to them sometimes in
my spare time to help me you know get
motivated to make the videos and i don't
know i just i definitely enjoy it
overall they do a really good job
especially
especially since it's mainly the same
people that did breaking bad so they
have all of that history on their belt
so feel like their montages and kind of
their teasers just honestly get better
and better but yeah a little bit a
little bit self-indulgent for sure
yeah and i'd add just that
i understand where this comment is
coming from if i were to try and just
objectively criticize the show you could
definitely say
the cold open from this week could be
removed and zero plot progression would
be lost
and typically you know in filmmaking 101
they'd say every scene has to have
momentum and progress things in some way
but if i put that aside and just say did
it work for me or not every cold open
has worked one way or another if i take
this weeks for example
just the first time i watched it there
was a sense of mystery and a sense of
melancholy so i was feeling that and i
was asking myself at first it looks kind
of black and white is this some kind of
a gene flash forward
no okay it's not that now i see
chemicals being mixed which in the world
of breaking bad the first place your
mind goes is drugs meth are we seeing
something involving gail maybe
then i saw the slide rule and realized
okay maybe this has something to do with
werner so the first time i watched it it
was three minutes of just trying to
figure out what i'm seeing and it was
exciting
now knowing the context of it i watched
it again today and like i mentioned
earlier it felt like a sort of memorial
to werner in the same way that the cold
open in the nacho episode felt like a
sort of memorial to that character
so
i understand where the comment is coming
from
but i just can't deny the fact that
they've worked for me and i could even
see myself re-watching some of them in
the future to just kind of remember the
show
and just remember some of the video
audiovisual treats the show has given us
yeah i mean i i i'm a big fan of the um
the teasers um i think that
they added dimension to things and
i i i could i could maybe get on board
with montages they they heavily relied
and maybe overused those at a point but
i i don't think that they've been doing
a lot of montages in season six am i
right about that would you guys say
they've used a couple like when they
were doing the key um duplication but it
wasn't really a montage
yeah
yes it was a little bit of a montage but
i don't think it's the the sort that
you're referring to
i mean yeah yeah they have they have
died down a little bit uh mainly i'm
thinking of season two during the
episode where kim first gets uh mesa
verde as a client we have two montages
of her just calling people to try and
get a client in that episode so yeah
they definitely did it a bit more early
on for sure
yeah i i was i i felt like they had
dialed that down a little bit this
season and yeah the like i said i'm i'm
pro teaser um i love that
last week
there were some images of this and i got
my my my video got dinged like they they
quit showing it to people because i
mentioned that there might have been a
different chemical process going on
there which was was i was definitely um
surprised at what was actually going on
there when we'll talk about that later
but
i think it adds to something for me um i
like to have that that idea in my head
it's it's not a lot of time like i'm not
really i'm not really worried about them
being like efficient with the amount of
time like they can make it you know it
it worked as far as the as as the
progression of the episode went on for
me
but um yeah i mean i've seen that in the
comments sometimes people don't don't go
for them so why don't we jump right in
and we'll start out talking about the
characters and what they did this week
and we'll start out with mr fring um
his first sequence was a you know
showing his paranoia at the restaurant
at los pollos
um he is like
not really i mean he
he he knows that lala's alive
in his mind you know he he or his heart
he feels like he knows that but there's
no there's no news nothing's coming in
so he's just kind of walking around
freaking out and
one of the weak parts of this for me and
i think for
viewers in general is that we know that
he's not in any danger whatsoever you
know we know how his story ends so
what's interesting
you know where this will get interesting
will be how he
gets out of this situation so
um here you know we see him he's kind of
trying to go about his day is going
about his business and it's not really
it's not really taking his mind off of
it and he hears about he hears one of
his customers mentions or he mentions
spice girls to one of his uh
customers and then he sort of spaces out
completely so
what are you guys thinking about this
place where gus is is that working for
you or what do you think
i think
one of the things they're showing us
about gus this season and we've seen
flashes of it before is what he does
when he's uncomfortable and nervous
and
part of the difficulty here is that
what's driving him so crazy is having to
sit there and wait and not know when
lalo is going to show up
so we're with there we're there with him
but to your point we know that he's not
in mortal danger so i can see why you'd
say that's where maybe some of the
patients starts to wear thin and
probably if i'm being honest with myself
where was i least engaged in the episode
it may have been here because
we've seen this from gus before when he
broke the glass for example that nacho
went on to use we've kind of seen him
rattled so how much more do we need to
see that
um but thankfully by the end of this
episode he finally has the epiphany
and at least i think is starting to
suspect
that the proof that lalo can't strike
that lalo needs to get proof first and
he's starting to anticipate lala's next
move
yeah so
there's there's a few times that we see
gus's ocd coming to play this episode
the first with his with him putting his
pen just perfectly on his los poyos desk
and then later you know at the safe
house scrubbing the top of the bathtub
with a toothbrush it's definitely
symbolic of his paranoia and anxiety
caused by his uncertainty of lalo but
really reminded me also of lyle
scrubbing those deep fryers in season
five
and and to add what you're saying pete
like we know how the story will end we
know lalo's alive we know more than the
characters i've heard the creators of
the show discuss this issue where
eventually it does get to a breaking
point where they have to catch the
characters up to speed with the audience
and i think we'll hopefully get that
soon um but mentioning lyle i love that
we see him again this episode ever since
they made him play a larger part in
season five you know makes sense they'd
keep him around but i'm glad to see that
he's still employed and doing well after
that traumatic experience last season
with gus i i really do connect to
smaller characters much more than other
shows um and then when gus started
zoning out at the customer i half
expected the customer to get mad at him
but we didn't end up seeing that um
then uh when gus mentioned the spice
curls my buddy uh phil mentioned how it
sounded like gus said spice girls which
really just made me laugh and uh to be
honest after watching episode 605 i was
craving some los pollos so when i got
some popeyes was the closest thing i
could get sadly um and then just as just
as far as gus freaking out uh i'm not
entirely sure why he marched outside i
guess he just needed some fresh air
after zoning out but kind of gave me
similar vibes to when gus stood out in
front of the sniper and breaking bad
although this was obviously much less
intense
yeah that's that's a good connection
there i hadn't thought about that but um
i did listen to
most of the insider podcast today and
they mentioned they were talking about
that scene where he walks outside and
him just being like you know i'm done
with this i'm done uh you know you know
waiting basically you know he's coming
to that realization that he needed to
act
i i i thought that maybe this this is
whenever i was you know doing my video i
thought maybe this is like he he says
spice curls that that's something that
he introduced at the madrigal meeting
that we saw in in season five
so that made me think that perhaps he's
thinking about madrigal he's thinking
about germany
and that's where he's starting to put
together
you know that like how gus is or how
lalo's gonna go about finding proof
ooh i like that i like that you think
about that nice cash because he because
he says spice curls and then he just he
jus that's whenever he like zones out
and turns his head so
there might be something to that i think
that i'll second that theory because i
think this show i mentioned it earlier
but it can't crack open a character's
head and show us what they're thinking
and also these characters so often don't
talk about what they're thinking so one
of the show's go-to tricks is to use
objects or items that tell us what's on
their mind the most popular example is
of course is the firo on yajo stopper
you know anytime kim looks at it you
know she's thinking about being gisele
she's thinking about the the fuel that
kind of took jimmy and her to where they
are now so it wouldn't surprise me if
they're doing that again with the with
the uh spice curls that's what
individuals
what's that
the spice curls that's right that's what
tells gus or that's what tells us that
he's now thinking
about madrigal
i'm not gonna lie i keep hearing you
guys say spice girls every time you
mention the curls i i just hear spice
girls i can't i'm
and that's a branding decision right if
you name your product spice curls you're
that's what you're hoping for right
you're trying to ride the coattails of
that famous pop band from i don't even
know the 1990s maybe
it definitely does have that similar
association gets stuck in your head
yeah so uh we have a super chat here
from seoul empire for two dollars thank
you for that
and he this is a little off topic but
we'll we'll talk about it now before we
move into the next thing and he wants to
know if nacho's dad's safe
hector knows where he is
skull emoji
so what do you guys think i though
gil and i actually talked about this
quite a bit
whenever that that episode happened and
uh adam was here and jim also we all
kind of threw in our our thoughts on
that um
and we were you know at the end of that
conversation we kind of thought that
it's possible that they'll never really
mention him again
and that's what it kind of feels like
right now is that that part of the story
is concluded
um you know what where are you at right
now gil like where are you do you is
that how it feels to you or
do you think there's more lurking in the
uh in that part of the the story yeah no
i that's i still feel that way i mean
i'll just i'm humble about it i've been
so surprised by the show so many times
but yeah right now my impression is the
book is closed on that story maybe
there's a kind of epilogue to it where
at some point we can see that mike is
doing something to check in on nachos
father and ensure that he's safe we've
also seen in the past that
mike did not like the fact that the good
samaritan that was killed by hector was
just buried and his family didn't know
what happened to him so he went out to
the desert found the body made an
anonymous call to the police to report
it so maybe he'll try to find some
subtle way to give nacho's father a
closure and ensure his safety so i could
see it i'm not predicting it but at the
same time i've been surprised by this
show many many times so who knows
how about you chad yeah yeah so in
regards to that i was pretty surprised
that we got the week or two time skip
between episodes three and four because
i honestly thought that episode four
would start up with kind of the
aftermath of the whole nacho arc um i
even thought that we might have seen uh
mike going back there afterwards maybe
barrowing or bearing uh nacho's body um
i would have liked to know more about
how gus uh gave the excuse that they
captured nacho when the salamanca twins
were chasing them the whole time and
suddenly gus has him now i mean i know
they did beat him up but i just kind of
wanted more of an explanation for that
and then also about nacho's dad um
you know it as much as mike says he
wants to protect him it's hard to you
know protect someone with a sniper scope
24 7. unless he has you know people
hired on his own terms to try and
fulfill that that promise um
you know i did really think that we'd
see more of it but now it's kind of just
seeming like it's a bookend and they're
gonna move on so who knows honestly at
this point
yeah i mean it they they they would need
to have a reason i think is is is where
i was where i'm at you know i think that
they it would be nice if they if they
touched on it but they would have to
have a reason that made sense and
right now at least hector and the
cousins they're not a major factor in
what's going on because it's all like
you know lalo is this thing that that
sucks all the air out of the room and
and we all know it's going in that
direction like you know showdown between
lalo and
and gus so it just kind of will depend
on how how he reconnects with his family
and how that plays into things i guess
we have another one here from francisco
chung
this is a
question which is is pretty easy to
answer did i miss something how did lalo
find out about the building of the super
lab and verner's involvement
he learned that when he first joined the
show back in season four i think it was
409 and 4010
he started following mike around and he
knew gus might be up to something so
when he first came to the us he started
um
looking into things and and he followed
mike and he killed fred at the travel
wire that's why he's
on the run right now because he
eventually gets caught for that
and so in that process
he actually talked to burner on the
phone
and he heard um you know something about
a south wall and you know keeping the
job going and that kai would be
um you know be able to
to lead the crew while he was out of
town or whatever so that's where that
came from we got a couple more here um
al washburn thank you for the 20 that is
very generous
two kim questions i meant to ask earlier
but missed the streams when the uh but
missed the streams when the ada
approaches kim about jimmy do you think
she reviewed lalo's visitor log and knew
kim went to see him
do you think this plays into where kim
ends up
um you know it's very possible
uh you know i i don't know
i've seen this pop up a lot in in people
asking this question
um
they haven't they didn't really bring
the ada stuff into this week so it's a
little hard to see where they're going
with that but i i think this is a fair
question um
i'm not sure that i have a
a strong inclination of whether she did
it or not yet chase do you have anything
about like do you have a strong feeling
one way or the other
uh yeah well i think this is actually a
really interesting question and i really
do wonder too because there has to be
some sort of proof that you know kim
went in and she went in as her actual
name and if suzanne erickson is putting
together all of these pieces of all the
people jimmy's helped and she's talking
to kim about it you'd think that you
know she'd put two and two together
maybe check and see who who visited lalo
at least and um
i mean we didn't actually see suzanne
erickson this episode but we kind of saw
the aftermath of it with uh
you know not a lot of people liking
jimmy at the court at the courthouse and
all that and
and i i wonder how that info got leaked
it's just kind of common knowledge now
uh suzanne maybe is she doing kind of a
dirty plan here to kind of turn in
everyone at the courthouse against jimmy
because he won't work with her
yeah that was my that was my take that
she was doing that intentionally in the
same way and it kind of mirrored what
you know
kim and jimmy were doing to howard um
and like you said it is an interesting
question
that we i just don't know that we have
enough information because yeah he
wouldn't even had a lot of guests you
know what i mean because he had a cell
phone inside so he was talking to the
other criminals that way so it's not
like if she looked at his guest list
like it could maybe just be him you know
jimmy and kim and nobody else you don't
really you know you don't really know
gil did you have anything you wanted to
add to this one
not really i mean i agree with
everything you guys said it's definitely
an open thread i don't think we've
finished with that storyline that's a
point i hadn't thought of that of course
the ada can see that kim visited lalo so
right now she's approaching it from
kim you better get your husband to talk
we're not building a case against him
right now
but dot dot dot
when that doesn't work maybe the ada at
some point will try to turn the
temperature up on kim herself so it's a
great question
yeah it's public information so it's
always something to keep in the back of
your mind
and al has a second question and another
20 so thank you again for that
and 506 it opens with the kim flashback
i still struggle to understand what the
writers were trying to tell us what do
you think the implications are and how
do you think they relate to how she is
which seems so far from that
um
i think that it just shows that you know
she kind of goes into this a little bit
when she talks with acker but i think
that it shows that there was you know
her her childhood was a little
it was filled with uncertainty you know
she couldn't really rely on the people
that you need to rely on when you're a
child we we don't see a mention or or
you know there's no indication about a
father here
and her mother is obviously um you know
has it has a drinking problem
so that was
that was my biggest takeaway i mean
generally
whenever you have a situation like that
you know you
you want to you want to you want to be
different than the person that has you
know whose behavior has uh
you know affected you in that way and
and perhaps that that's that's another
thing of her trying to not be the kind
of person that her mother is gil do you
have anything you want to talk about as
far as that
yeah there's there's one i agree with
all of that and the thing i'd add to
this and this is partially inspired by
something tom schnauz the writer of this
episode said
which is that
he saw that opening
as implying kim may have walked away
from her mother and that relationship
was never reconciled between them
that called open was in the same episode
where it was wexler v mcgill so at the
end of that episode
kim suggests to jimmy that they get
married and that was after jimmy really
betrayed her trust so when they have the
tense argument at the end of the episode
and she's yelling at him i fully
expected her to say we're through and
instead she goes the other way so
connecting that with the cold open i
think that maybe kim regrets the way she
left things with her mother that she was
never able to repair that relationship
and now she's almost correcting too far
the other way where it's going to take a
lot for her to just give up on a
relationship she gave up on her mother
she regretted it and now with jimmy
she's not going to do that again so even
if jimmy
does something that deserves a it
deserves getting him dumped you know
really betraying her she's not going to
walk away
yeah so that this is interesting
this is this is really a loaded question
because usually uh with uh for example
kim and howard with their past i mean
it's kind of mysterious right we don't
know too much about their past and
usually when they drop little hints
about it it's kind of just during small
talk maybe something that a casual
viewer might miss such as you know kim
talking to mr acker or back in season
two i believe with the rich schweikart
interview and uh howard this season
talking to his therapist about his wife
and possibly his father but um this is
really the first time that they took you
know kim's past into you know front and
center and i think it does play a part
of the whole you don't save me i saved
me kim was very independent from a young
age i think that's a good point you made
gill where uh where maybe she's
estranged with her mother i don't even
know if her mom is still alive like for
all we know she could have died uh in a
car crash a drunk you know drunk driving
car crash could be something that is
just permanently unresolved and um thing
about kim is we don't know if she was
always a goody two-shoes uh maybe she
could have been you know giselle or slip
and kimmy growing up and then she
decided to go on the straight and narrow
as she said uh with the richard
interview she didn't want to work at the
hinky dinky or whatever that store was
so now we don't really know too much
about kim's past and it's possible that
she might have a dark past um but i do
think that this cold open with her as a
kid really does show her independence
with you know willing to walk home by
herself at night
yeah those are all good those are all
good points and
we did we did talk about that a little
bit last week uh some of those same
things and
that's that's kind of one of the things
i don't want to linger here too long but
you know uh this next question is about
kim ii and and space windu thank you for
the ten dollars asks i'm starting to
think or says i'm starting to think kim
will be in the in jail in the breaking
bad timeline
and you know
the
the mystery of kim you know that this is
you know this is
this is where we're at i mean this is
what what this is the big last big
question you know what i mean and um
i think that
i was complaining a little bit about
being behind the characters but this is
the one where i'm kind of
i'm kind of okay with where we're at
because it's just there's just so much
riding on what we learn about those
things you know like when we learn about
what her her history was
does she really have a dark
side that she's you know that she's been
suppressing and and all of that stuff so
the idea of her being in jail that is
definitely something that i have thought
might be the best um
the best uh theory about it i mean i you
kind of say that like i said with an
asterisk of like hey um but we don't
really know yet you know what i mean but
just with the information we have
the idea that that phone call is coming
at a specific time you know on on
jimmy's birthday in the future and
things like that you know there's a lot
there that kind of makes you think that
it's possible
you know whenever um you know that she
might be in jail and that's why that her
and jimmy aren't together in that
timeline
what do you guys think let's just real
real rapid fire here gill
jail or no jail in the breaking bad
timeline
jail
it's possible huh and
uh yeah it's just one of the many
possibilities of kim's fate is she in
jail does she die she's still with saul
um i think she might take things too far
end up going to jail because i don't
think saul
i don't think kim dies honestly because
saul would be too depressed during
breaking bad but
what would almost be worse for dying for
her is getting disbarred and losing her
job and losing you know pretty much her
whole self-worth so i think that being
in jail is almost a worse fate for her
and considering you know it's kind of a
tragic show that might be the case
yeah one thing i'd add is if you ask me
again in 10 minutes my answer might be
different because it is such a question
mark and like you said it's one of the
fun things of the show right now is we
just it's really hard to predict where
she's gonna end up
someday not too long and you know in the
not too distant future we are going to
know
and that's pretty exciting so i guess to
take it back to where we were at um gus
uh you know he we see mike get snuck
into his house
i like the little connection there with
the people from last week seeing her
drive in with mike in the back of the of
the van uh or the whatever that was um
suv i guess
he's kind of tired of this because you
know he's he's working hard out there
and he can't get anything
to you know
there's nothing that he can learn about
where lalo is gus is freaking out that
that's making everybody else kind of
freaked out
um
i'd like to you know what i like to hear
about this part was that
you know
him not knowing where lalo is is what's
causing him the problem this is a guy
who loves to be in control of everything
like he you know you mentioned
chase you mentioned like his ocd
characteristics and some of the things
that he does
you know he's definitely he needs to be
in control of things so this is you know
incredibly uncomfortable for him
and one of the ways that he does you
know he has these little things that he
does that take back control like
incrementally like he's he's literally
with the toothbrush cleaning the grout
in his shower because he can control
whether that's clean or not you know and
then then at the super lab we kind of
see that
but on a bigger scale you know he's
coming to the idea that
uh lalo is is he can't lalo can't hurt
him until he gets the
proof otherwise the you know that's
beyond what the cartel will allow to
happen so
he he makes that he has that epiphany or
you know whatever and he
he has a plan that i guess i met you
know it's gonna involve lowering
using that to his advantage and luring
lalo in as far as i can tell
and so we see these steps of you know
taking back control and you know i liked
how they illustrated him hiding the gun
where he you know he finds the spot he
he paces it off he knows exactly where
that is you know it's it's implied that
he could find that in the dark maybe
even if he needed to because
he knows exactly where it's at and he's
just that precise
um
so
what do you guys what do you guys think
about this whole this whole uh at home
and at the super lab part of
gus's uh story here
and for me i just i agree with your
entire read of the situation so i feel
like the only thing left to add is the
question mark of what exactly is he
planning there because it it's really
hard to imagine that gus's
he intends on having a face-off like a
classic western duel where he's gonna
draw his gun from where he hit it and
shoot lalo in their eventual showdown so
i'm just really curious where that's
going to go
and i'm also really wondering about the
broader implications of it because if
you think about
gus versus hector
that gave us a big window into gus's
psyche we learned how pathologically he
needed revenge against hector obviously
it tied in this big tragic story for
nacho
so
i can't imagine that all we have left
from lalo is gus kills him end of story
it has to be some major building block
for gus mike jimmy or or kim so very
curious where it's going both in the
plot and in kind of the character
development the last thing i'll add
is the last time we saw
gus plant a gun somewhere it was
essentially giving it to nacho in the
hopes that nacho would shoot and invite
return fire so i wonder if there is a
clever scheme going on where he wants
lalo to find the gun maybe there's a
meeting with the cartel with uh with um
juan bolsa
and lalo gets backed into a corner pulls
the gun and that gives gus the excuse he
needs to kill him and have the blessing
of the cartel that's like a half-baked
idea i came up with a couple of hours
ago but just throwing it out there in
case it ends up being right
yeah yeah that's an interesting idea um
well first off i i do have a few more
things to say about gus and the
toothbrush versus the grout um you can
really tell he's just taking his
aggression out with this toothbrush it's
almost like he's torturing himself just
doing anything that he can to get his
mind off of the current situation and it
really is an elaboration of what you
said pete where he walks out from los
poyos and he's just had enough and and i
think him going to the super lab and
planting that gun is is part of that
even though he has no updates no news on
lalo he wants to be proactive and and do
something himself just in case um
because it does see he is suspicious
that lalo may be somehow looking for the
super lab which you know is why he hides
that ankle gun there i'm not sure why he
counts his steps before doing so um but
is it possible that we could have a gus
versus lalo confrontation down in the
super lab cape uh imagine how messed up
it would be if lalo dies down there and
they build the super lab on top of his
dead body since you know the concrete
isn't poured for the floor or the walls
yet it could really take a new meaning
to putting up the south wall it
definitely makes me think uh i mean
if this does happen it would really make
me think about lalo whenever i see any
super lab scene in breaking bad as well
just knowing that lalo's party is
underneath them
yeah it's funny because um you know
there's been a couple of
of recurring um
theories that that pop up on reddit and
and people
have really
they don't like them right so germany
was one of them and uh i think gus or
lala being
buried in the south wall is another one
and um
i think you could even add to that maybe
lalo seduces mrs ziegler like people
were really uh against these ideas
before and now that the lalo thing came
true i saw some i haven't looked at uh
at reddit too much since yesterday but i
saw some
uh
people bringing up the south wall that
that's guaranteed now because obviously
you know
the the theories that they don't like
are all coming true
but yeah i think that there's something
to that you know that if if i don't know
if he's gonna be buried in the south
wall or any of that but if he was killed
down there then
you know or even if there's just a major
confrontation there
you would always think about that
differently during the series like
you're saying chase
so i think from there we're you know
we're um
we might as well move along into kim
because we still have a lot of ground to
cover here and um
let's go
uh you got you wanna you wanna switch it
up a little bit do you do you wanna um
gil do you wanna to to lead us through
kim and then we'll have chase lead us
through howard
sure that sounds good
yeah let's do it yeah basically kim
towards the beginning of the episode we
see that she's
she has that paranoia now that she knows
lalo is out there so she does the old
chair under the doorknob trick to prop
their door shut
and uh jimmy sees that paranoia
and he says that line that we mentioned
earlier you know he's glad that lalo is
dead and
kim still doesn't tell him the truth
um
i guess we can pause there and just ask
any any thoughts on that scene before we
go over to the viola stuff
i just wonder you know what is actually
motivating her to not telling jimmy not
that i need an answer to that question
necessarily but
i think it's the question we're supposed
to be asking because we're we're
we're seeing her act in ways that you
know it sort of just keeps getting
ratcheted up where you know she's doing
things that we never thought that we
would see her do
and this is this is a kind of a big one
i think you know
yeah and i think uh we've talked about
it last week
and
i think she's not gonna tell jimmy until
she absolutely has to
and i think the reason she's not telling
him is the same reason that mike went to
her with this information rather than
jimmy we've seen in the past how jimmy
will act when he worries that lalo is
out there he went to mike's house banged
on his front door until he got some
answers versus kim who said we have to
go on with our lives you know what are
we going to do we can't just cower and
fear forever so right now i think she's
just carrying it herself because she
knows that
there's a risk jimmy will fall apart if
he has to carry this burden so until she
needs to i feel like she's going to keep
it inside
honestly gil that i could not agree more
and uh yeah just to quickly summarize my
opinion from even last week's episode i
was in this initially surprised that she
didn't tell jimmy but the more that i
think about it it the more it makes
sense because you know on one hand kim's
trying to protect jimmy by keeping the
secret from him jimmy's been feeling off
of his game due to the trauma with the
desert shootout along with the lalo
confrontation because not much time has
passed since uh the end of season five
with season six picking up you know
directly after so jimmy's just now
starting to get back on his feet after
this kind of week or two time skip and
learning about lalo still being alive
would no doubt just ruin his mentality
again so you could see this as kim
trying to protect jimmy but it's also
selfish of him due to wanting jimmy to
be confident in order continue the plan
to take down howard kim needs jimmy to
be in the right mindset so she doesn't
tell him about lalo in fear that you
know this would throw jimmy off of his
game again
uh
she also might think that she can
possibly handle it on her own ever since
they got married they agreed no more
lies when obviously that's not the case
jimmy used to always hide the criminal
side of his life from her and now she's
hiding it from him and uh yeah as you
said gil of course kim could eventually
end up telling jimmy whether it's at the
beginning of the next episode or down
the line you know kind of as you said
possibly when she needs to due to maybe
being confronted by lalo or just
something something to the point where
she has to involve jimmy now uh but you
know he he's obviously gonna get pretty
upset but situation might be so dire
they you know they'll have to just kind
of shove that down and save that for
later and deal with the situation but
now it's it's been another episode and
kim still hasn't told jimmy and the fact
that jimmy says you know thank god he's
dead just emphasizes the false relief
that jimmy feels about it something that
kim doesn't want to shatter so you know
now it seems like kim is trying to carry
the burden herself of knowing that
lalo's still alive and could possibly
come after them but it's a bit
irresponsible because if it happens to
jimmy like if lalo confronts jimmy out
of nowhere he won't see it coming and he
won't be prepared ahead of time the way
that kim kind of is
yeah it's the old um finger guns
switcheroo how you know jimmy had the
finger guns at the end of season four
kim had them at the end of season five
he was keeping everything from her now
she's keeping everything from him
it's it's a little bit on the nose
whenever you think about it like that
but what you pointed out was was
definitely true you know
there's a there's a switch in how
they're doing that and i just want to
interrupt for a second to touch on james
james egan
not to be confused with james egan from
the ceo of lumen in the series severance
um
australian 799 thank you for that
he has the question you think mike has
fully become the mic from breaking bad
if not what finally gets him there
um this is a good question that i don't
have an answer to i don't think he is i
don't i don't think he is um
i think they made a step towards that in
um
in last season whenever they had him
sort of come to that conclusion that
he's gonna do what he's good at you know
he's gonna deal the the
he's gonna
um you know he's going to play the hand
that life has dealt him kind of
situation but it it doesn't really match
up for me what do you think about that
gail
uh it's it's hard yeah yeah i'm kind of
in the same boat as you where
i don't necessarily think he has that
far to go
but if you asked me to detail out what
are the remaining steps or how does this
mic differ significantly from the mic we
saw in breaking bad it would be hard for
me to point out a lot of specifics i
mean clearly the mic in breaking bad has
more of an appetite for violence he's
not looking for it but it doesn't
make him as uh
he's not as opposed to it as he is and
better call saul i think if he met
another nacho which i guess he kind of
does in jesse and breaking bad i don't
think he'll be as ready to take him on
as uh as a sort of pupil
and we see that with jesse i mean at
first he kind of just thinks that we
need to get him out of this whole
situation because he's an unknown he's
erratic he's causing problems eventually
he decides to take him on and start to
mentor him
uh so
yeah i guess this is a lot of me saying
i don't think he's quite there yet what
will get him there i assume it's
something involving lalo though last
thing i'll just add is i think nacho was
a big part of that too that was such a
tragic situation and i think that just
shows it that helps him recognize
inevitable conclusions he helped nacho
here and there and ultimately he at
least so far was able to protect nacho's
father
but
he couldn't he couldn't help nacho
escape his ultimate fate
so in the future i think that will make
him a little more a little more
calculating over who can i truly save
and who can't i save
so i think he took a step i don't think
he's quite there yet
yeah so so i definitely agree with what
you're saying um
in in regards to comparing nacho to
jesse uh there's a scene in breaking bad
you know the famous scene of i had a guy
now i don't you're not the guy you know
initially you think maybe he's talking
you know about gus or something like
that or gale but uh i i think you know
there's a popular theory floating around
that he was possibly talking about nacho
in that moment now honestly you know
obviously when they made breaking bad
they didn't have better call saul in
mind and nacho and lalo weren't
characters yet but they just do an
amazing job at rec conning situations to
make sense for the flow of breaking bad
and uh something that this show does so
brilliantly is just being able to work
within the confines that they've already
set for themselves and in regards to
when
when mike will become you know you know
no half measure mike um there isn't
really an exact moment
it's kind of just his character arc
throughout the entirety of better call
saul because at first you know he he
goes to great lengths to not kill anyone
even in the game with uh tuko in season
two and then by season four you know
he's like okay well i'll kill someone in
the game but you know innocent people
that aren't in the game are off limits
and uh i think by the end of the show
he'll eventually kind of fall in line
with the way he is in breaking bad just
kind of following what gus wants him to
do um so yeah there isn't really any
given moment of him becoming no half
measure mike just kind of the same same
thing with you know the moment that
jimmy became saul goodman or the moment
that walt became heisenberg it's a slow
gradual uh evolution or
de-evolution you know it's not not one
exact moment there's a lot of different
stepping stones
yeah it happens in in in steps and um
i i think that they probably will give
us an event
you know maybe something we haven't seen
yet to just make a you know
make it all feel really
connected with breaking bad but you know
they might they don't really need to
either
uh we have another one here for
from the recovery 716 thank you for the
499. he says haha i listened to all your
channels from my better call salt
coverage
gla
glad you guys are collabing
looking forward to that season two
tearless key week
thanks again for that
yeah yeah just uh i'm really excited to
get that season two tier list out i did
like a season one tier list before
season six started i was gonna get
season two out got a bunch of copyright
claims uh yeah i was talking to pete
about it also my other uh my other
youtube buddy george drake and uh so i
just have to go back in re-edit a few
things might have some time this week or
next week to do it and then uh during
the mid-season break i'm going to be
doing the rest of the seasons kind of
leading up to the final half of season
six but yeah glad i'm here loving the
stream so far it's a lot of fun
and we have one from tanner r thank you
for the five dollars what bcs theory
would anger you if it turned out to be
true
gill you want to go first on this one
yeah so i'll i'll first give the caveat
that whatever if a theory turns out true
i sort of trust the writers to do it in
a way that even if i didn't like it
initially i'd say you know what in
retrospect that makes sense
but the first one that came to mind
is that lalo and kim will run off
together she'll leave jimmy for lalo i i
i picture it i can't picture that's such
a meme
yeah but uh
yeah maybe the the run actually i won't
say my runner up because i have a
feeling one of you might say it but
that's probably the one that would anger
me the most
uh yeah sorry for interrupting i i just
love that you know i think i think it's
such a meme uh i definitely get comments
about it but it's it's kind of the same
thing as like oh you know kim turns into
wendy from breaking bad and and now that
we've seen wendy and kim together you
know it's not like she had an outer body
experience or anything that thankfully
that meme is dead but now i even have
people messaging me being like oh well
maybe wendy is kim's mom is like
just never ends it's like the tobias
thing from the walking dead it just just
just never uh morales or whatever it
just never ends um to answer the
question though probably howard dying um
i've been predicting since uh last year
when i did some season six death
predictions that howard will eventually
become so depressed from what jimmy and
kim are doing to him that he might end
up killing himself
now you know there's the possibility
where he might get involved with the
cartel side of the show and you know
we'll discuss that more in a little bit
but
but yeah i don't know definitely howard
dying i i think it might happen but i
really hope it doesn't
yeah i think that
i think that that was i was i would have
to say the same thing that gil said uh
kim running away with with lalo or or
just becoming the um
just becoming the the cartel lawyer or
or i guess i could extend it to just
being there behind the scenes i i really
hate the idea that that she exists in
and breaking bad um
the whole time is actively a part of
of saul's life but we just never saw her
um i think i feel like that feels like
it undermines part of what already came
before
now they could like you said i'll add
that caveat that you said gill that i
trust them to if it does go that way
that it'll make sense for what they were
trying to do
and there's a lot of variations on her
being around but not around you know
during the
breaking bad timeline that could be
really fantastic but
just her and like him and her in that
golden palace like um
sitting around planning and you know
laundering money that would that would
be
a bummer for me i really wouldn't enjoy
that
unless they really did a good job with
it
um let's let's touch on these other ones
and then we'll jump back in uh daniel
cortez thank you for the two dollars do
you think howard will break up jimmy and
kim
i would say no what do you guys think
i mean it's the the like the the
situation with howard may play a part in
that but i don't think he will
personally
do that just based on what kim you know
like kind of the conversation that they
had at the end of uh season five where
he tried to tell him
what to think about what was going on in
their relationship and it ended very
badly for him
um well i mean
i mean i don't i don't think howard's
gonna go out of his way to you know
directly sabotage their marriage or
their relationship i think maybe you
know the result of them rooting howard's
career or his life might be too much for
them to to handle and and you know they
might go their separate ways because of
it but you know you know if anything
they're gonna be the ones breaking up
howard and his wife honestly
yeah
i agree with both of you guys that i i
think
if they do end up breaking up uh it'll
be in large part because of however the
howard situation resolves itself uh one
idea i've heard floated that i think is
a possibility is if things start to go
too far with howard will jimmy try to
sabotage kim she wants to move ahead
with the plan he doesn't could that
create some tension between them i think
that's a possibility
okay and gil this uh this one here is
actually a nice uh transition back to
right where we were on uh in our
discussion a second ago so you want to
talk about this when you want to read
this one and we'll give our thoughts on
this sure well thank you for the super
chat and he asks can you please tell me
why gus planted the gun in the lab
laundromat instead of keeping it close
as a chilean at henrysimo it doesn't
make sense
help
so uh i guess chase or pete who wants to
speculate on this
i mean i i already kind of gave my
prediction i think that he kind of keeps
it there in case he ends up confronting
wallow down there i mean i don't know
why lala wouldn't bring a gun himself
but
i mean i feel like it's just some sort
of method of self-defense and uh you
know
gus gus could get another ankle gun for
all we know i mean i feel like it's
significant that he it's that same gun
that he had you know on his person the
whole time but it's not not out of the
range of possibility that he could just
get another gun to keep on himself as
well
yeah i mean it's it's pretty it's it's
so much of a chekhov's gun kind of thing
like that
it makes you question it you're like oh
maybe it's a red herring you know um
i think why he put it there
you know it like yeah it has to be part
i think it's more of a
of a trap than just part of a plan you
know i mean like that's what it felt
like to me the whole
pacing out where it's at and knowing
where you know exactly how to get to it
that felt like
it was
it was part of a trap that he wants to
set for lalo i don't know exactly how
that the mechanics of how that's going
to play out but it goes beyond just like
um
it's not simple like there there's
there's there's there's importance to
what's happening there and
you know when i was watching that i
thought maybe that this is you know
he has this he has this realization that
he can't kill him so
he could use that against him and he
could try to to actually lure him there
you know in one way or the other he's
either gonna you know obviously
we'll get to this but obviously lalo's
going to track down who bought the uh
slide rule and
he's going to be going in that direction
you know gus doesn't know that
necessarily but he does know that he'll
eventually
come to those people who work there
because they're the only people
that that that know about it and you
know so i think that we'll see um
you know what his i think it'll depend
on what his plan is to actually get lalo
on to the location
but um i'm not really sure i understand
the angle of uh as a as a chilean you
know let me see
henro misumo uh it doesn't make sense
like i'm not really sure where where
they're coming from do you guys have
anything on that
now i just agree i think it's a trap of
some kind and i floated a couple
theories earlier about how that trap
might work i doubt um i'm correct in my
theory but one way or another i don't
think it's as simple as i might need a
gun later let me hide it here i think
it's a little more clever than that
yeah i i i just genuinely agree with you
saying it's a chekhov's gun i mean first
we saw it on his ankle i think there's
two separate moments first in the last
episode in this episode where we see him
looking at it and um now we have this
whole scene of him him placing it there
again i don't know why he did the pacing
he kind of deliberately counted his
steps before he placed it i don't know
that's going to play into it but you
know they're definitely setting it up
where this is gonna play some sort of
significant part in the story
let me add one more thing to my theory
um widely checked the power cable why is
he checking the steps he wants to make
sure lalo ends up standing in a very
specific spot
and then he's going to use the power
cable to electrocute him he has to die
in a really interesting way gus got half
his face blown off lava was going to be
in an electric electrified corpse
oh my god if that happens you you set it
here first man
yeah now we're getting into wild
speculation you know well that's uh that
could be yeah i would agree that they do
need to give lalo a memorable ending and
uh
i guess we need to go back to something
completely
disconnected from that and talk about
viola yes
yeah kim meets with viola her old
paralegal when she was working for
schweighardt and coakley
and
the it's she set it up as this is just a
meeting for us to catch up old friends
but really she's there to suss out some
information she wants to find out who is
going to be the mediator which is
basically somebody that's going to
oversee a meeting between sandpiper
and uh the lawyers and their clients uh
to come to some kind of out of court
settlement usually so she wants to know
who the mediator is going to be and she
gets the name it's an ex-judge rand
casamiro
so she brings that information to jimmy
they look at a picture of the ex-judge
and jimmy comments love the stash that's
a lot less face to worry about and kim
says you know unless he shaves
and that seems to be another step in
there in their plan
so so any thoughts on the meeting with
viola any thoughts on what this means
for
next steps in operation howard
you can go first chase
yeah sure so
at first you know they showed this in
the trailers and at first i figured that
kim was gonna talk to her former
assistant because she wanted to hire her
as her own personal assistant uh you
know i figured we'd see both jimmy and
kim hire an assistant this episode jimmy
with francesca kim with viola and in a
way that still could happen in the
future uh if or when kim does get to set
up that pro bono practice with the
multiple lawyers that's what she was
talking about with cliff and it's really
what she wants to do with the sandpiper
money when they get it but you know then
i realized that you know what you were
saying gil you know kim is probably just
catching up with viola in order to get
close to her again due to her mentioning
that she's working on the sandpiper case
now i assume that kim probably already
knew that which is why she wanted to
meet up with viola in the first place
but she still just asked uh leading
questions in order for it to come out in
conversation naturally as to not raise
suspicion of her intentions but you know
just the way that viola is talking up
kim i wonder if kim will screw over
viola or throw her under the bus in some
way we'll pretend while potentially
using her against the sandpiper case you
know to her benefit which would really
hurt just considering how much viola is
praising kim and saying how much she
looks up to her
yeah that felt like it was the setup to
me was that
here is someone who knows kim
professionally and personally on a
certain level and she just
you know she's in awe of her she's an
inspiration for this person
who she's there to
deceive
you know what i mean it's all under
false pretenses and yes she is doing all
those things that that viola thinks
she's great for
but she's also
working behind the scenes to
bring somebody down you know
get this whole thing moving and
she's involving this person
you know in in that in that scheming
and you know what i think about like one
of the things you you mentioned lyle
earlier jason and this is another one of
those examples of these great side
characters that they're there they're
almost invisible until they get their
chance to come up and then you're like
oh that's right this this this character
is great you know like this is such a
great character they just like come out
of the shadows and i really thought this
was a fantastic example of that and
i would say that her and like aaron and
in
especially ed begley jr stuff in this
episode there was so much little stuff
like that that i really appreciated how
these how these characters like just
added those little flourishes and the
little bit of screen time that they had
that's the thing you see these side
characters here and there you don't
really think much of them but then they
really utilize them to their fullest
potential i mean how many ernie fans do
we have from the earlier seasons right
like never would have thought but yeah
they
they're just so memorable and i really
appreciate them like i love bill oakley
like number one bill oakley fan here
yeah
yeah i think they do a really good job
of making the background characters feel
like real people and mentioning bill i
love that they gave him a little bit
more to do usually he's just a
downtrodden
lawyer that's opposite jimmy but last
episode he got to tell jimmy why
everyone sees him as a pariah
double fist in those bags of chips
i always think that you know like i
always loved how jimmy comes to him with
food because he has just the worst
diet of just being so busy that he eats
out of the the the vending machine all
the time
well jimmy really knows how to how to
talk to the courthouse people like he
brings bill oakley some snacks he brings
the receptionist you know a little ty
beanie he really has gotten all these
people on his side which makes it such a
big deal that possibly suzanne erickson
has turned them all against him
yeah
and we'll have to uh let's look at these
these these um super chats really
quickly before we we get back around to
finishing up with kim big ralph thank
you for the ten dollars the pacing for
this is going to go down in the dark
gus will pull the plug walk to the gun
in the dark
i need to be on this show to help you
guys
yeah i mean that's a popular um
thing that i saw
uh like i said i i think that
he
he wants to know where it is like so he
can find it and that would definitely
make you think that it might be in the
dark um
you guys have anything that you want to
add to this
all right i think that i think that's a
possibility i think it's a good theory
um maybe you know it makes sense why he
was fidgeting with the lights you know
that has has to come into play somehow
yeah i mean he can find that spot and
then he can he knows it's
it's x amount of steps over to where
it's at and i don't know why you need to
know the number of steps if it's not in
the dark the part that i'm having
more of a of a confusion on is how is he
planning on getting lawler there to
where and how do you shoot somebody in
the dark i mean i get the idea of
getting a gun but like you can't see the
person you're trying to shoot
you know what i mean is he going to walk
over there with him as he's pacing that
out or
i think there's some unknowns still
involved but i i do understand big ralph
thanks again for that i mean i do
understand the what you're saying and
and the inclination and i guess maybe
that's really where where i get a little
bit confused is is how this all comes to
be important you know like how he ends
up having to to employ that
uh special skill
yeah i don't know i mean like uh there
is that part of the conversation where
mike talked to gus and and they pointed
out kind of that hole in the wall and
said you know it's it's filled up with
dirt no one's going to get through but
they are kind of implying that gus
suspects that law that will somehow make
his way down there
and when the lights turn off you notice
that they they kind of shut off and
there was still some light and then the
rest of it turned off maybe lalo ends up
in the spotlight he gets shot but who
knows you shot him because everyone's in
the dark
yeah that's possible
conor o'keefe thank you for the 199 how
are you going to shoot and kill someone
you can't see yeah he's got that same
question that i have and i think we
addressed it do we need to add anything
else to that
uh honestly i've said about all
yeah anymore about viola
uh nothing from me
all right so then chase you can take us
through
howard
yeah i do want to add actually not on
viola but just one more thing on the
rand casamiro thing
because what exactly are they planning
to do with that mediator and i just
found it odd that they seemed so fixated
on his appearance
and especially the way that jimmy said i
love the stash that's less face to worry
about and maybe i'm just thinking about
it because we've seen so many body
doubles i don't think we're getting a
rand kasamiro body double
but in a sense maybe maybe uh they do
want somebody to be mistaken for that
character
and again if i'm doing crazy
theories we already saw we've seen jimmy
take chuck down by getting him to accuse
jimmy of a bunch of things and sort of
make himself look very paranoid and it
didn't work out too well howard almost
falls into that trap here because when
cliff comes up to him and tells him
everything he's seen howard sort of
stops himself from going on a tirade
about jimmy all he says is i have a
jimmy mcgill problem and he walks away
to take care of it but what if at some
point they want howard to see what he
believes is rand casemiro so when we
finally get to the point where howard is
making public accusations about jimmy
setting him up what if included in that
list of accusations is
i saw rand casamiro working with them
behind the scenes or i saw him doing
something he shouldn't have been doing
and that's part of how they ultimately
take him down
um but that's just that's something that
occurred to me earlier today
no
interesting i
i got i got no clue what that's gonna
come down to but yeah yeah that's a good
theory
yeah and we can we can talk about a
little bit more about that when we talk
about them together in jimmy's part of
the story too so i'll
i'll circle back around to that because
i think everything you're saying is uh
is is on the money i think that that's
gonna be um
a big part of the next steps and uh yeah
let's let's let's circle back around to
that in a minute so we do have a few
super chats here amber t
nice to see you uh with the 420.
thank you for that
if lalo finds kai what info will kai
give up and i think you know i kind of
touched on this in my video um the
the
we don't really nobody really knows much
about this by design
but he can tell him details on what you
know like we were we were building this
big thing we had to you know prop it up
from below um you know there's some
there's technical details he knows but
they don't know anything about like
where it's at where uh you know what
what they're actually gonna do in there
later so yeah this is a good question um
do you guys have anything that that you
you see that he might be able to give
him
i mean
i mean yeah
well first off when you have a gun to
your head or something like that you
know you'd be willing to say almost
anything and uh especially since kai
never really liked mike or gus and he
was always kind of the the outgoing
backlash type of guy i feel like he'd
he'd be willing to give up information
you know it's just kind of you know
threatening you know and maybe he
doesn't even need a gun to his head so
uh yeah we'll probably talk more about
that when we get around to discussing
the lala side episode but i definitely
see a wallow and kai uh scene in the
future
yeah
gail
uh honestly nothing to add i mean i
think they have kai and maybe some of
the others have every reason to talk i
don't think they're happy about the way
things went down but even if they did
talk i can't really think of what
specific piece of information they could
give lalo they could definitely give him
more info and maybe he can use that in
combination with something else to find
the proof he's looking for
but i i really don't know
yeah and
we have another one here from latasha 10
thank you for that kim is the first
person that saul disappeared probably
risking her life and breaking protocol
calling him once a year
somehow they'll end up back together in
the end as their new identity so not
really a question but a statement
is this one that you agree with gil
i think it's a possibility i think
in my predictions video i may have even
said something very similar to this but
like i said earlier my thought on where
kim ends up changes minute to minute i
do think that the disappearer will come
up in some way this final season i know
sadly the character himself
due to robert forster's passing likely
can't appear i don't see them using any
kind of trickery to have the character
actually on screen but it would almost
seem odd to me that with so many
characters likely ending up in the
crosshairs or in mortal danger and
needing to run it would almost seem
weird to me if it doesn't come up um but
it would also seem like a little bit
played out how many times have we seen a
character use that uh that plot device i
mean that was jesse's ultimate
conclusion so it feels equally odd to me
that this is the way kim would go but
it's also a possibility so
real quick uh chase i just wanted to
i don't know if we made this clear
beforehand but
we don't really talk about the teasers
here or or things
from the future so um just because i
know gill doesn't watch them so we do
that okay
yeah i was literally just about to ask
that before i answered so i'll kind of
keep it teaser free here
yeah that's uh that's why i interjected
here because i do agree with what you're
saying
on both levels uh gil
but
and and that is really my my aversion to
this is that they've used it a number of
times already but some somehow it has to
come back into the story so okay sorry
go ahead chase you can uh you know you
can talk about this uh super chat now
no it's all good uh so yeah kind of
spoiler free here um we all kind of you
know thought that nacho would be the
first one to be disappeared but uh
clearly that didn't happen so uh yeah i
do think that maybe maybe kim will be
the first one to get disappeared uh kind
of kind of the meme theories like you
know wendy's kim another meme theory is
that ed is actually her father
i don't really think that's the case but
something that's been floating around
and um just the thing with overusing the
disappear i mean they used it for walt
they used it for jesse multiple times or
i guess he didn't go the first time but
he ended up you know an el camino and
then uh then obviously saw his genes so
it's just a certain point of of
overusing that and utilizing it
correctly and i you know i i was
thinking about it recently like are we
even gonna get an explanation for how
saul gets the the connection and since
we know that mike doesn't know about ed
how does he get it
um i don't know i i just hope we get
some sort of satisfying conclusion and
and they they can use ed you know sadly
robert forster passed away rest in peace
but they still can use elements of the
vacuum cleaner guy without actually
showing his face you know just show the
red van pull up maybe show someone going
inside of the building so there there
are there are workarounds
yeah and that's one of the pluses
actually if you think about it of them
using him so much is those little cues
they could that would really actually
pull on some heartstrings because you'd
be thinking about the character
who is so essential to this thing and
how the actor has passed away and yeah
that that's an interesting angle there
uh amber t again thank you for the 420.
she says if howard survives and looks
like she hopes that he will
will his marriage
what do you think guys do we i mean i
think that
that's a possibility since that's really
the only thing we know about his
personal life is that he plays golf and
he has a wife um that he could
maybe he'll get maybe maybe he'll lose a
hand and he can't play golf anymore but
i mean i think that there's a
possibility that his marriage might
have uh
have some issues what do you guys think
and they could go for the ultimate
tragedy if you kind of flip your
questions so
howard doesn't survive but his marriage
does maybe we get a scene of him with
his therapist and he says you know
things are great at home everything's
working out we've resolved all our
issues and that's just in time for his
character to die and then it will be
horrible
but i
i totally thought you were gonna go
in a different way of his wife keeping
him around after he was dead
i like to say i you know i think i'm
getting exposed like a dark part of your
mind that i haven't seen before i'm
intrigued
oh yeah yeah you know i
um
well i i don't know i mean
i i did a whole video about howard's
family and then learning about cheryl
his wife and you know the mystery of his
his father and um i do think that that
part of dialogue is kind of you know a
chekhov's gun in its own and i'd like to
relate it back to uh rebecca with chuck
back in what was it season two and then
season three um
you know we only kind of saw hints
rebecca like her name on the piano sheet
music before we finally got introduced
to her so it could be the same thing
here where we hear about cheryl and then
you know when tragedy tragedy strikes um
possibly with their marriage maybe we
actually see her but
it could also just you know show that
it's possible for characters to live in
this universe without actually seeing
them on screen
yep and um we we got one here for
in another direction from the recovery
716 thank you for the 9.99 do you guys
think that the flash forward call and
quite a ride for francesca could be
oakley and i'll just say right now that
that is not something that i had ever
thought of before
and he says that he thinks that jimmy
rats on lalo and gets back in oakley's
good graces and breaking bad maybe
that's why he blames nacho
what do you think
chase why don't you go first
oh man well that that is just a loaded
question i mean
i don't even remember how long the video
i did on that was about a year ago is
like maybe like 20 40 minutes going
through all the different possibilities
and the exact wording that they used in
that scene but
long story short i think it's gonna be
howard or kim because the date that he
tells francesca to take this phone call
is on his birthday jimmy's birthday so
and then it says refer to you know tell
him jimmy sent you not tell him saul
sent you so it's probably going to be
someone from the better call salt
timeline i mean it could be bill oakley
we know that you know
we saw him in american greed so you know
we know he makes it out of this one but
uh but yeah i don't know i'd i'd
probably you know put my money on howard
or kim but that's an interesting theory
for sure
yeah i'm thinking about the way that
this is worded now and i i i thought
i i think that kim is the person that
that that's going to call that francesca
is going to answer for maybe this uh
commenter is asking about
who he gives the card to as far as
giving that to francesca right where he
says
telling jimmy you know this is tell him
jimmy uh sent you or whatever
um
that's what i would think that maybe he
told he told her oakley as a lawyer
i i don't i don't think that he would be
on the phone calling him on his birthday
gail do you have anything to add to that
no pete i agree with your take the one
thing i would add
not about bill oakley but just i think
jimmy ratz on lalo i have thought that
something in the realm of jimmy ratting
on lalo is possible and could lead to
the infamous
uh jimmy thinking that lalo was sent
somebody after him and him shifting the
blame to nacho so i think it's a
possibility
yeah i'm not really i i've seen a lot of
that in my comments people talking about
him um
ratting and i just don't think unless
kim changes her position on it we'll see
jimmy do that because jimmy didn't even
really have a strong feeling one way or
the other he just went straight to
asking kim what what he thought she
should do and i thought that was a
really weird character moment where
he just sort of abandoned you know his
his decision making in that process but
it just kind of goes to show you that
everything he's doing right now he's not
really doing because he wants to do it
he's doing it because
he's he's trying to uh you know keep his
partner happy
jacob zabal
thank you for the 499 do you think kim
could be pulling the strings from jail
and breaking bad
um
i don't know about that i mean i think
she could be in jail we touched on that
earlier
uh i don't know what string she would be
pulling there's one thing and we're
gonna i i don't really want to derail
too much but we're kind of already there
so
let's just let's just run with it a
little bit here um there was a thing
that that that struck me or it has been
kind of creeping up in the back of my
thoughts in the last few episodes and
it ties back to that opening teaser of
the the you know just the opulence and
and over-the-top thing that that saul
goodman has going on at home
and i was thinking about like you know
this how this thing is just sort of
could get out of control with howard you
know that they're trying to just bring
him down a notch but maybe it's gonna
you know it's gonna escalate in a way
that they have to keep up their
you know like they have to they find
themselves in a situation where they
have to keep up the the appearances you
know
like jimmy's not not living in that
house because he's trying to impress
potential clients and and drug dealers
but be kind but because he's trying to
keep up the story that they have to
invent
in order for whatever is happening at
the end of this to make sense i don't
know does do you understand what i'm
what i'm conveying there
like that that that's it's a symbol of
everything just getting out of control
and them having to stick to it because
it's it's it's it's uh you know it's
necessary for whatever the scam is that
they're running
are you is this is this coming to sort
of agreeing with um the thought i was
having in uh some of our earlier
conversations
that the opulence of the house doesn't
necessarily mean kim isn't there that it
could be more of the how do we create
the image of saul goodman like the
flashy car we also need the flashy house
is that kind of what you're saying
well i mean it kind of depends on
whether the you know the story is that
she has to to get out of to i don't
think she's there right i don't i don't
think she's there but
either she's gonna have to get out of
town or she's going to be removed from
town you know what i mean
so in a scenario where she has to go on
the run
then maybe that maybe that there's just
some weird thing that they were trying
to do that that he just has to be a
complete
sleaze you know to keep up appearances
but then you know he's still jimmy so he
can't it's like the switch in episode or
season two he can't help himself he has
to flip the switch
if he's gonna be a sleaze he has to get
out there and he has to you know launder
some money or what have you
and then he ends up you know kind of
creating walter white or or making water
white possible and then if you look back
you know one more step then her her
creating saul goodman you know
one step removed also
kind of
made walt all to white possibly that
that does sit right with me more than
the idea of her being there actively and
breaking bad and pulling strings more
like she helped to craft the character
of saul goodman got the ball rolling and
jimmy carried it forward that that kind
of makes more sense to me
um
i mean like kind of in regards to what
you were saying pete about you know
maybe kim's gonna take this too far i
mean maybe she feels like she already
has and so she she can't stop now you
know even though she totally could but
uh
it is kind of a parallel that i found
between kim and walter because in the
last episode in episode four cliff gave
her an out and a way to get that pro
bono office that she wants the sandpiper
money for so in a way even though she
might still have to try and fund it
herself she said he won't write a writer
a check but
she has a way to do what she wants
legitimately and it's the same thing in
breaking bad season one with elliott and
gretchen giving giving walton out a way
to you know they'll pay for his cancer
treatments they'll give him a legit job
but he he tr he chooses to go you know
down a dark path and i think kim is just
in the same boat
yeah
and amber t again 420 why do you all
think toilets are doing so much this
season i wondered the same thing um
i did listen to the insider podcast and
vince gilligan said that this was his
idea and he he gives a story of where it
came from that's it's a little explicit
i guess um he went to look at a place
with someone
and there was a toilet that had been
disconnected there
that someone had used as if it was
connected
and so that made an impression on him
and he wanted to
have a
uh disconnected and a toilet involved in
the scene for some reason when he was
writing it do you guys have any toilet
related um information to add to that
i would just add that i think it's not
just this season i think it's almost
been a recurring motif in the show going
all the way back to season one where
when jimmy's finally having some success
one of the first potential clients he
meets with is the guy that wanted to
file a patent on his talking toilet
chandler that's yeah yeah that's right
and then earlier this season oh i guess
this is part of what you're mentioning
but earlier this season he clogs the
toilet i feel like it's it's it's funny
and it's kind of just jimmy's lot in
life that he's always down in the dirt
down in the mud
and dealing with disgusting
things like toilets
toilet humor is a term right i mean
that's a that's a thing isn't it
yeah for sure
yeah and i think it's very um probably a
nod to that as well yeah
jeffrey townsend thank you for the 10
canadian dollars i think that's what
that is uh speaking of boxing's berna
ziegler was punching above his weight
marrying that babe
if lalo doesn't kill kai mike will kai
definitely spills the beans to lalo
yeah and we talked about that we don't
really know what he can tell him but he
can give him more information and i
think both gil and chase touched on that
idea that he's more inclined because of
what happened with mike and that makes
sense
and yes uh uh frau ziegler was a very
pleasant looking um
woman and you kind of got it you kind of
had the idea of why like it was kind of
a weird character tick of werner's that
he um
he was so uh so connected like you know
like he went to such great lengths to
try to reconnect with his wife and i i
feel like that kind of validates some
some of that there
do you have anything you want to add
gail
i just love how quickly they can develop
a character with so little screen time
and the introduction for her is just
this interesting thing that you can't
not notice where she's listening to the
trivia behind her and kind of mouthing
the answers to herself
so it just uh it's like what we were
saying earlier she's not she's more than
a background character but she's
definitely a character with not a lot of
screen time and they find a way to very
quickly make her feel human and make it
feel like there's more to her than just
oh that's werner's wife this is a fully
developed real human being that is about
to be in lawless crosshairs
yeah and i liked how that sort of um you
know they they sort of mirrored like how
whenever verner was in the in in the bar
he was overlooked you know he's
listening to other people talking you
know with the uh then when the way he
pronounced the
uh wheat beer or whatever you know
heffa-feissen
half a bison yeah so it was um
yeah i thought that was a nice touch
that they were they had similarities you
could see why he was drawn to her and
you know it made it made it also made it
you know we'll talk about this in a
minute it also made it make a lot more
sense that that lalo was able to apply
his charms because why wouldn't he you
know what i mean
like it wasn't out of place if he was
just
walking up to some random person and you
know
trying to uh talk her up
mr qwerty thank you for the 4.99 what do
you think about jeff the cab driver is
he just some guy or does he have
connections to the underworld
love all your guys videos
i think he's just some guy um
he i think he knows who saul is from his
time in albuquerque and
he wants to leverage that to his
advantage in some way but um
i don't think he has connections to the
underworld i didn't get that feeling
what about you chase are you there
yeah yeah i'm here um you know gene
versus the cab driver is just
another another loaded question that i
just love thinking about because there's
so many variables you know is is he just
some guy like you said i do agree
regardless of who he is that he wants to
leverage this info on uh
on jimmy and or gene and um yeah i mean
like is he involved with the criminal
underworld is is he a gangster of sorts
is he an undercover policeman i i don't
i don't think he's that you know i think
he really is a guy that just moved from
albuquerque uh
but yeah i'm really interested in seeing
it how it's going to turn out and he
definitely has some malicious intent
like a a hundred percent i mean gene is
paranoid in all that you know and it is
a question of is gene's paranoia going
to be his downfall but you know gene was
paranoid about jeff in in season four
and in season five you know his paranoia
was validated almost it's kind of the
same thing with the recent episodes with
uh
kim wondering if she's being followed
and and she's paranoid and that's
validated and then
gus is gus is paranoid about lalo and
and we the audience know that lalo's
alive so that's validated too so
you know you know just because you're
paranoid doesn't mean someone's not
following you right
yeah yeah i think that's you know you're
you
you're right on the money with the uh he
has malicious intent he's not a good guy
um but beyond that it's hard to say
there's a it's a pretty you know there's
a pretty wide range of different things
or different boxes that he could fit
into
he came off as uh
so sorry go ahead
no you go ahead i was going to say to me
he came off as almost a criminal wannabe
like he saw
saul goodman as his inn because he knows
saul's in that world and now he has this
kind of connection because he knows his
secret that nobody else knows so it
almost seemed like to me like he was
excited about that that maybe this is
his way into the underworld
yeah that that's a good point too um he
he does have that sort of uh around the
um
around the fringes but not really
hardcore
that's a good that i i i'm with you on
that um
jp thank you for the 199 uh he wants
opinions on the boxing scene also all
the germany stuff and
as soon as we get through these other um
super chats here we are going to be
getting on the boxing scene and the last
thing we're going to talk about is the
germany stuff so
thank you for the 199 but can we uh
ask that you wait just for a minute so
we can talk about them in the natural
order that they happen
because if not we're just going to have
to do it again yeah yeah no i totally
agree i was about to say the same thing
honestly for
sure um norwood wildlife ten dollars
thank you for that will saul get killed
at the cinnabon my
my initial gut reaction is no
how about you what do you think gail
think saul's already been killed at the
cinnabun he's yeah
now his soul has been killed
will will there be a salt goodman corpse
created at the cinnabon my gut also says
no i don't i if he dies i don't think
that's where it happens
yeah yeah if he dies it'll be somewhere
more more private i don't know i don't
know some sort of confrontation with
jeff in a back alley or a parking lot or
something but yeah i don't i don't
really think that it's gonna be this uh
sort of you know public shooting type
type of situation but that definitely
definitely is dead inside i do agree
with that point
yeah i think that you know if you think
about the uh you know he does have the
metaphorical death there and i think
that if you think about the
uh poster for this season which um is
kind of hidden in the background here i
think he's going to be reborn there as
saul not not die there i mean it might
lead to his death
it may lead to his death but i don't
think that um
i don't think cinnabon is the important
part of that that equation
one more i don't know we got a couple
more sorry
stu sasser two dollars thank you very
much nacho's signing shiny gun was seen
before in breaking bad um
i don't know
i mean there's shiny guns everywhere do
you guys know what this is referring to
uh not not rigging a bell in particular
now i'll try and watch over the chat to
see if someone gives uh gives a specific
example but i mean who knows honestly
i i tried searching nachos gun breaking
bad in google and
nothing jumped out at me so that's all
i've got
all right so yeah we'll we'll keep an
eye out on that if it pops up in the
chat
um
whisper gaming 9.99 thank you very much
for that in the season in season one the
opening song is address unknown maybe
kim escaped to her hometown in nebraska
and made a deal to meet jimmy there but
he never found her
um the idea of her going back to her
hometown it just seems like
um
it's hard to imagine her where she's at
right at this moment
just like going back home with her tail
between her legs i mean she's um
she's got a lot of other options and she
doesn't seem to be very uh
happy or you know she wasn't happy she
actually left her home because she
didn't like it there
um but you know uh
this is an interesting take that maybe
that
she didn't just know she you know that
she's there but they just haven't run
into each other
chase what do you have on this
particular comment
uh well a few things first off i love
just kind of highlighting the undress
unknown as i said earlier i really love
the breaking bad music i love the ink
spots um i feel like better call saul
has introduced me to a lot of really
good 50s and 60s music i i would have
never heard of same with uh you know not
to do real too much but the fallout
games it's where i first heard the ink
spots um and and uh this super chat
that's a good interpretation there's uh
obviously a lot of different ways you
can interpret it uh my original
interpretation is just that uh this all
just up and disappeared one day so you
know the i really feel like it's about
him disappearing and you know uh kind of
with the whole my echo my shadow and me
which is you know one of the other songs
that's used during the gene scenes um
it's just really about his new life as
gene and and how he just kind of up and
vanished and who knows maybe like if kim
is still alive and she hadn't already
been disappeared then maybe she doesn't
even know where where uh saul is as gene
maybe she thinks that saul is just m.i.a
maybe he got killed somehow i mean who
knows right
yeah there's so many possibilities gail
uh you know when i think about that
phone call we discussed earlier
where
we're expecting somebody to call on
jimmy mcgill's birthday and that quite a
ride flash forward and a lot of us think
that could be kim
i imagine that is to tell kim what
happened that jimmy is disappearing he i
don't know at that point if he would
know where he's going
but it might be the trigger for her to
try and find him at some point and if
you ignore
where all the chess pieces are right now
and don't even think about how we get
from point a to point b but you just
take it at face value that we have these
it's almost a love story you have jimmy
and kim
we know that jimmy disappears into this
sad life we don't know what happens to
kim your instinct is to say there's
going to be some kind of reunion you
know if this were a romantic comedy or
if it's a tragedy there's an attempted
reunion there's a near miss and they
don't find each other
it feels predictable
but this show is unpredictable in the
sense that sometimes they do go the
predictable route if you go back to
breaking bad walt essentially sacrificed
himself
in in an effort to save jesse and it
worked and then jesse escaped that feels
like a sort of predictable ending so you
can't always go the unexpected way all
that to say
i i think it's possible i think i think
i think it'd be really compelling to see
what does it look like for jimmy and kim
to meet after they've suffered a lot of
consequences for their actions
and have to reconcile with how they got
here i think that'd be compelling
uh real quick i do want to elaborate on
the whole uh gene and kim reunion theory
um
the thing is right uh gene is in omaha
nebraska and kim's hometown is on the
nebraska kansas border but the but the
whole thing so it's like
did he intentionally go there because he
knew he'd be close to kim but
um when you're watching uh the original
episode where saul is with ed and and
he's you know getting his fake id photo
taken and all of that um it seems like
ed is the one that you know chooses the
omaha nebraska location because
he says you know you're going to be in
omaha nebraska and then saul says oh
what's there you know so so it's you
know if saul was the one that chose the
location because some people can like
jesse was able to choose to go to alaska
but
at least how the breaking bad dialogue
was and again they could retcon it
because they obviously wasn't think they
weren't thinking about this uh back when
they made breaking bad but uh yeah just
key moments on that dialogue there i
think ed did choose that location so so
who knows if if that was intentional or
not and if they will reunite because of
it
yeah that would feel dishonest to me if
they retcon that honestly because it's
not it's not a question i mean it's a
throwaway line that that they build gene
off of the throwaway line and he talks
to walt tells walter in the basement but
it's not up really to debate and of
whether he chose to go there or not
based on
how how it played out in breaking bad
ed sends him there you know what i mean
yeah yeah definitely
uh like so i'm agreeing with what you
said but i'm just being a little more um
firm about like the i think the retcon
would be a bad idea
yeah for sure
yeah that's that's the thing that just
kind of kills it for me that jimmy went
there intentionally is that it really
does seem like ed chose the location so
who knows
uh certain certain chingatan
i did a pretty bad job with that but uh
sir torchington no wait now we got it
499 um thank you for that maybe think
about putting spaces in between the
words and your name if you want me to
say that a little bit better
two quick ideas gus won't be the one to
pull the trigger on lalo
and jimmy will be the one to leave kim
thoughts um
yeah there's a there's a tendency to
think that jimmy will
leave kim
in some kind of you know self selfless
manner to be heroic or or whatever i i
definitely i you know that i feel like
that
there's a natural satisf satisfaction
that would come along with that
and gus not being the one to pull the
trigger on lalo
i think that i saw a lot of comments in
my last video of people think it's going
to be mike
don't really know
how either one of them is that much
better
because i didn't really think it through
but um
i mean generally gus doesn't pull the
trigger i mean you know somebody else
does
so i think there would be a little bit
of impact there if he if he was kind of
like the box cutter scene you know to
see him
um actually get his hands dirty but
you know it could it could uh could go a
different way
let's let's uh let's hear what you guys
have to think go ahead gil you can go
first
yeah i don't think i have too much to
add on the gus side other than i think
we're all expecting it to be something
more clever than gus picks up a gun and
shoots lalo so even if he is the one to
pull the trigger i just i feel like it's
not going to be that simple
uh on jimmy will be the one to leave kim
i do think it would be more interesting
for one of them to make a choice to
leave the other than for them to be
forced apart by by one of them dying or
by circumstance forcing them apart i
think to me that would be
uh at least as it stands right now that
feels more interesting to me but the
same caveat i came before if it goes a
different way you know the writers
usually find a way to make that
feel organic and feel surprising and um
and thought-provoking
yeah yeah so uh
so first off for a kind of kind of
elaboration on on what pete was saying
uh he mentioned the box cutter scene and
that just kind of sparked an idea in my
head i was thinking about about a week
ago um
i don't think we've ever seen gus pull
the trigger of a gun i mean we've seen
him kill people but he always does it
with his hands right like the box cutter
scene and then with arturo in season
four in front of nacho he has killed
people but it's always in some sort of
gruesome devastating way meant for
intimidation uh if gus wants someone
dead that's what he has mike for right
so i don't know if this will be the
first time we've ever seen gus pull a
trigger but uh yeah i believe we haven't
actually ever seen that on screen and
then for uh jimmy being the one to leave
kim i
actually did a did a recent theory video
that uh kim might might screw over jimmy
uh and betray him and just long story
short throughout seasons one to four or
even you know one to five we'd think we
thought that uh kim would leave jimmy
because you know she's had enough with
his schemes and his cons then going into
season six we're thinking oh jimmy will
leave kim because you know she's out of
control now is slipping and slipping
kimmy but it's possible that uh kim
could get the sandpiper money and just
run and just and just betray jimmy and
maybe that's why he's so so cold-hearted
and breaking bad and you know making
comments on francesca and stuff like
that i mean it's definitely just one of
those many possibilities about kim
yeah i've said it on the stream and
multiple times that one of the things
that's that's
so
great about this final season is that
all everything is still on the table
they really haven't
they might have written themselves into
corners in certain ways but they they
haven't really
made it they haven't really narrowed
down
the different options as far as what's
what's viable or not
the recovery 716 thank you for the 499
again
he'd love to hear kim say i need a dust
filter for a hoover max extract pressure
pro model 60. can you help me with that
yeah and like i said i the only problem
i have with her disappearing
is just that they've used it for for
several characters um
and i think we kind of touched on do you
guys have anything else to add on that
just that i initially misread this
question and i i saw can you help me
with that as being outside of the quotes
like he wanted us to help with hearing
kim say that
and i'm just gonna say i don't have i
don't think i can do a great kim
impression
and i definitely don't know any
disappearers in real life so i can't
give you their number either
the only thing is that if she does say
it it might be in her own original way
right like
saul says it properly jesse just kind of
blurts it out he doesn't remember the
exact phrase so you know if kim does say
it maybe she'll say it in her own way
tanner r thank you for the five dollars
again howard's license plate showed the
year as 2005. breaking bad starts 2008.
what do you think will happen in those
three years and walt and jesse appear
and walt and jesse appear in the
mid-season finale question mark
uh his it says 2005 but that is usually
whenever the sticker um
expires so the timeline is 2004 right
now as far as i know
um yeah yeah there there was uh there
was a scene in 602 where we saw a
close-up of uh betsy kettleman's
paperwork and it said like may 4th 2004
or something like that and then uh they
did the howard scheme with wendy on the
18th so it's about the the middle of may
right now for them in 2004 i believe
yeah
and so that you know the idea that it's
in the breaking bad starts in 2008 is is
definitely correct
what happens in those three years i
mean i don't know
it could just be that
whatever happens in 2004 is so
monumental
that that we'll just know that
what happens in 2008 makes sense based
on where we left the characters the last
time we saw them i mean i do think we'll
see a little bit of overlap
we definitely know that walt and jesse
are appearing in the mid-season finale
i'm not really sure on that
um i i don't really i mean something has
to happen there but we have a lot of
things that are going on right now so um
i don't know what do you what do you got
gail what do you think
um
so i
i've often so thinking about how this
show is going to bridge with breaking
bad i've always assumed that at some
point we're going to hit
okay we've established the status quo of
saul goodman's life
and not that nothing interesting happens
but the next monumental thing that
happens is it gets involved with walter
white
so
i think like it's kind of what you were
alluding to that something happens in
2004 that's so major it makes 2008 make
sense i think that's probably going to
happen
and
so when walter and jesse show up
i don't know that it'll be a flash
forward but i wonder if it will be
we get to that status quo and then we
somehow skip ahead either a time jump or
uh you know we go back to a montage
where we see saul goodman at work and we
kind of lead into the breaking bad
timeline
and
and then once we get to that overlap
period where maybe we're seeing some of
breaking bad from another perspective
maybe that's where they show up and my
gut would tell me that's somewhere in
the second half of the season
i am just as a psa in the chat i'm
seeing people mention credits maybe they
have leaked just by looking at the
credits uh what episode they're in i
don't know if it's accurate or not but i
immediately glanced away to try not and
see to try not to see that
um but those are my thoughts on it at
the moment
yeah so so just to elaborate on that
very last thing you said gil uh i won't
i won't answer that for you but i have
had people message me um about that and
uh so yeah i have a pretty good idea on
what episode they're gonna show up uh in
and uh kinda kinda wish i didn't uh i'm
i'm jealous of your bliss
good morning moto moto v-log
vlog moto vlog
five dollars man that was uh two in a
row that i couldn't read i was just
actually distracted by the fact that we
hit 1k as far as people here that's the
first for this so
that's pretty cool to see um
i think nacho's dad will get unlived by
lalo
mike could not protect papa what about
protecting gus also more payback for
hector your thoughts
um
i i just don't you know we we went into
this
pretty deeply in the episode three
stream
and my biggest thing is i don't know to
what end um
jim made a good
good point that it would just be awful
and that sometimes uh this show has a
history of making things awful um
i i it doesn't make it it doesn't it
doesn't serve any purpose as far as as
like
making the salamancas more more menacing
or
or wanting to see them taken out and
breaking bad i mean breaking bad does a
good job of that all on its own
so they're kind of superfluous in a way
i think to what to what's important
about the ending of like you know as far
as better call saul sticking the landing
you know i i see a lot of times
like even we talked about this a little
bit last week where people are like well
i'm tired of the kim and jimmy storyline
they really need to get into the to the
main story and kim and jimmy are the
main story here um
yeah the other stuff is not it
it's connected it's in the same universe
but it's not the main story so unless it
unless it serves what's going on and and
mike to a lesser extent i mean mike is a
big part like what happens with mike is
a big part of breaking uh better call
saul
and that brings in that whole side of
things but um
unless it's for the purpose of serving
what's going on with kim and jimmy and
largely jimmy becoming the salt goodman
that we know
um
i i just don't really i don't really
think that much about it like i don't i
don't i don't feel like it's as
necessary as as other people do what do
you think uh chase
uh well i mean just in regards to this
you know i already kind of mentioned
about um
about mike not being able to protect uh
uh papa you know 24 7 but you know a lot
of people ask why didn't nacho go down
shooting and you know try to take as
many people out with them using bulsa as
a meat shield and i think the reason is
is if he would have done that it just
would have increased the likelihood that
the cartel would have seeked revenge on
papa so by just taking himself out and
no one else i feel like he he minimized
uh that chance it's still possible but
he he really tried keeping it to a
minimum
yeah i think he kept up his end of the
deal in that and i think that was a big
point
and again um
you know people thought that that would
make it more tragic if he went through
all of that and not you know
and still wasn't able to save him but i
i just really don't i don't really like
it unless it unless it's you know
there's more to it than that what do you
got gail i just i mean i agree with
everything you guys are saying um the
one thing i'd add is that right now gus
has eyes everywhere they suspect that
lalo salamanca might show up or the
salamancas might show up so i mean is it
possible that of course they can't be
everywhere at once but right now they're
at def con one so at least at the moment
if if everyone in the audience and it
seems like a lot of people are thinking
that nacho's father might still have a
target on his back because the
salamancas are just so viciously thirsty
for for payback even when they've
already had it they want more maybe it's
possible that some resources are being
or some resources are being dedicated uh
to watching him
um but but again yeah i i it doesn't
feel right to me that he would get
killed and not right as in morally right
of course that doesn't feel right but
from a storytelling standpoint it
doesn't feel right that we're going to
revisit that
but
with so many people bringing it up
i mean i have to be humble and say
i might just be wrong you know so so
we'll see
yeah
and that just goes without saying i
could always be wrong
impossible pete oh god if i find a
nickel for every theory i mean i did a
theory a few weeks ago that that mike
would be the one to kill nacho and
obviously that fell flat so you know as
likely as you think something is you
never know but uh yeah would would
really suck if nacho died in vain and
his father still ends up dying
yeah
and yeah and like and if you guys are
curious about that go back and watch our
season three stream because jim uh from
bald move he made some pretty good
points in there that
made me reconsider it and you know where
it was kind of a closed you know i was
kind of thinking of it in with a closed
mind of like you know it just wouldn't
be good and uh he brought up some
interesting points in that
uh jeffrey townsend thank you again for
the 10 canadian i'm curious
on an opinion as to why jimmy did not
have much of a reaction to kim having
their front door barricaded
would you not have ha thought something
was up um
i didn't really uh i didn't that didn't
really occur to me when i was watching
the episode did either of you guys have
uh you guys are
are both uh i'm here do you hear me okay
yeah okay okay
all right i just noticed that that i was
seeing a muted thing on my screen and it
was weird that you both did it at the
same time um
so yeah did you have it did you guys
think about that that he didn't notice
about the barricade
i mean initially when kim put the the
door there i mean put the uh chair there
i thought i mean that's going to be a
little bit of a giveaway that she's
worried and maybe that lets on that she
knows something he doesn't but i think i
kind of stopped thinking about that when
jimmy made the comment oh you too
like he just reads that as even though
lalo is dead as far as we know
you are also still paranoid so he didn't
seem thrown by it and i think that's i
think it's as simple as that he's he's
still feeling paranoid so he's not
surprised that she is too
yeah
see when i first when i first saw that
uh because because that part happens
before jimmy's like oh i'm glad he's
dead so at first when he's like oh you
too glad i'm not the only one i'm like
wait did tell did kim tell him about
about lalo still being alive but
but now it's now it's just kind of you
know jimmy's still suffering from the
ptsd he's probably still paranoid of
that he's he's relieved that he thinks
lalo is dead but maybe he just thinks
that kim is still paranoid like him
because of his ptsd
yeah good points good points
bruh
thank you for the 4.99
how do you guys feel about the theory
that hule
or kim
that was a little bit worded a little
bit strangely but
he's saying he's saying huel ate kim
i think he's not oh
no
i'm not sure if he's saying eight or is
hell is kim well read the second
sentence i think it'll clear it up oh
okay this would explain his exponential
weight gain in between the two shows um
oh no
i gotta say i think uh jonathan in the
chat who's saying i think we gotta get
to discussing the rest of the episode
this probably is not um appeasing him
but uh sorry peter i'm gonna cut you off
well i just think that um it would be
hard
this if he if he did do that then jimmy
doesn't know about it because jimmy
would not be the happy-go-lucky guy we
see in breaking bad if he knew that his
the guy he he generally has a round for
security ate his wife i mean i think
that that would be a little bit of uh
of a
unsatisfying um thing there
i mean good meme good meme bro i think
he's on to something you know wendy is
kim um
kim runs off with lalo all of that um i
mean i mean i would like to you know get
back to talking about the episode but i
really do enjoy all these super chats
and just the outpour of support here is
just is just wonderful and
it's really getting my head turning
about all of these different uh better
call cell topics some of which i haven't
even thought about in in over a year
such as you know the the you know four
or five flash forward and things like
that so so i mean i mean keep them
coming you know
yeah absolutely um and i just wanted to
uh check because gil you were talking
about
time or we're at two hours so if you
need to bow out at any moment you know
just just let me know and yeah i think
i'll set a time limit for myself and uh
i mean just there's so many people here
and so i feel bad leaving but i do have
things i need to get back to so i'll say
i'll stick around for like another 15
minutes um and one thing i'll say is you
know i think we're allowing the
conversation to be guided by a lot of
the super chats but i think that's part
of the purpose of the live stream is
we're not necessarily intending to do a
full recap of the episode it's kind of
like let's talk about all the stuff
that's on everyone's minds and then i
think each of us are doing recaps and
and full episode reviews on our
individual channels so if you get to the
end of one of these streams and somehow
we didn't talk about that one thing you
want us to talk about chances are we at
least each have individually discussed
it on our channels
yeah yeah
i come here
yeah i come here i i make a detailed
recap and before i i do this and i come
here so that i can have a discussion
with my guests and
answer people's questions and if they're
gonna if they're gonna make a super chat
then i'm definitely going to
uh you know i appreciate that so i'm
definitely going to respond to it and
you know it would be it would be an
ideal situation that people only
threw out super chats about what we were
talking about but that's just not how
conversations work so you know
this is this is i'm i'm fairly um
comfortable with the way that this this
plays out and i if like if you do like
as gil said if you want just a straight
recap then you know i've got one right
over there in my
on my channel that you can watch if
that's what you're looking for
all right so one more on the on here
we'll we'll clear this one off before we
move back into the thing if there's no
other ones and that's rakes muhammad
thank you for the 499. how do you think
they introduced the disappear and
gill um do you have anything you want to
throw out there because like i said
there there i think that there has been
some indications about that
uh i think uh okay i find it so funny
that uh i i don't watch the next time on
preview so it feels like about a
thousand people are just tiptoeing
around just to protect me from from a
few spoilers that have been dropped uh
my thought and maybe you all know that
i'm wrong about this but it's the vet
caldera he's he's been the go-to guy
that knows everybody in the underworld
so i've always thought it was going to
come from him
nice
and all right there's one
go ahead
oh i was i was just going to make a joke
and say no comment but uh to actually
elaborate on what gil just said uh i'd
like to challenge you gil i mean uh
if caldera is the one that gives jimmy
ed's number
then why can't mike get ed's number two
from caldera because mike never knew
about ed in breaking bad so that's
that's the only thing because i do think
it is caldera but that's just kind of
irking me it would kind of seem a little
bit illogical
well maybe it never came up right it
just yeah i guess
i guess caldera isn't really in the
picture and breaking bad anymore either
at least that we know of right so i mean
who knows where that goes
the frenchie is fry 199 gus finds love
theories and this refers to something
that um peter gould was he gave kind of
like a run down of all the characters
and whenever he was asked about gus
that's what he said gus finds love and
it is kind of a weird comment based on
what we've seen so far there's nothing
uh
there's not love is not in the air in in
gus's storyline right now so i i i'm
wondering about this too i don't have
any great answers um
some of the the more out there theories
were that he was gonna hook up with
howard um
that seems less likely at this point in
the game
um you guys have anything for that
uh maybe maybe we're not interpreting it
we're interpreting it the way that you
would at face value that gus finds love
for himself but maybe this is a vague
way of saying gus finds the concept of
love for example he finds out that jimmy
and and jim jimmy and kim are in love
and decides to protect that love
or or he protects nacho's father the
love of a father
uh so these are theories i've come up
with in the last like 60 seconds yeah
but but just the idea that maybe we're
gonna find out that this this uh thing
peter gould said is accurate but just
not in the way we thought
yeah no i should i should
add that yeah they they were all
vague and uh open to multiple
interpretations that was sort of the
point of how he threw the stuff out
there so you know it it it definitely
wasn't like he's literally going to you
know
find the life partner or something like
that
i mean i think gus already did
potentially find love and uh
hector and donald audio might have
ruined that for him so you know all of
the reason why gus wants revenge
yeah
robert lukowski thank you for the 199
there's no uh question attached so i'll
just uh thank you for the donation
mod mary 4.99 thanks again who is
due the sandpiper money professionally
jimmy or saul who is kim legally married
to
um
kim is married to
jimmy mcgill i think is that does
anybody well so one little nuance is
that jimmy mcgill has not legally
changed his name to saul goodman he asks
yeah he asks for a dba at the end of
season uh four doing business ads so he
practices as saul goodman but his real
name legally i believe is still jimmy
mcgill
absolutely okay
so thanks for clearing that up gil
because that's been something i've been
wondering about because i initially
thought that was the case but in the 601
uh breaking bad flash forward when you
look at the pill bottles you see that it
is prescribed to saul goodman so maybe
he does eventually change his name uh in
between 2004 and 2008 but yeah it kind
of confused me when i saw that in 601
yeah i thought that yeah i thought that
was that was something that was weird
too there really wasn't a reasonable
there wasn't a good reason for that to
have for the for his medicine to have
that name on it but i think we'll
probably learn more about that as we go
on as far as i i don't think that
there's any legal shenanigans going on
um i think that's what this is kind of
of
leaning towards um
i think that
that whatever kim even if kim is trying
to scam jimmy or or she gets the
inclination to scam him later
i don't think she'll have any problem
getting that money off of him if that's
the case you know what i mean like i
feel like that that's not going to be
the the point as like she's going to try
to
you know use her status as his wife and
then be foiled by the fact that you know
something's not up on the up and up but
the paperwork but you know we'll see
and now we are uh
we're clear on the super chat so if you
want to pick back up with the episode uh
chase with howard you can just start
right back up
yeah for sure so first off i just want
to say that whenever you think you've
seen the last of aaron brill she pops up
again like uh
i i mean her her actor does a really
good job but just i i just got a bone to
pick with her um but so her howard and
cliff they're speaking to the residents
of uh sandpiper they're becoming almost
as impatient as uh jimmy and kim in
regards to settling the case uh
the elders do bring up a good but dark
point you know they're all kind of near
the ends of their lives they don't
really have that much time to wait
around just to squeeze out every last
possible drop now howard does a great
job selling them on the idea to wait a
bit longer and
you know i i kind of mentioned this
quickly earlier it kind of parallels
jimmy back in the first three seasons
working on elder law with elders in
general because you know jimmy isn't the
only one good at talking to elders and
considering how proud cliff seems to be
of howard i initially thought that you
know maybe he's coming around he won't
confront him about the whole thing but
but as you know it's clearly not the
case so
after multiple schemes to uh slander
howard's good name uh cliff's had enough
and he decides to confront howard about
it now as we know uh cliff uh mentioned
to kim that his son has a drug problem
which has obviously taken a lot out of
him who knows how many years cliff's son
has been dealing with the drug issues um
you know it's probably why cliff
recognizes what a drug baggy looks like
from 601 it it and so he just has all
these preconceived notions of what an
addict is and
i don't know you know it's hard to help
an addict get better in the first place
especially if they don't want to even
help themselves and you know having that
whole parent-child relationship creates
an even larger disconnect due to the
child wanting to disobey or not take
them seriously and
i just feel like cliff has heard
everything in this regard you know he
has that personal connection from
denying the drug saying that he doesn't
do them or saying he's not doing them
anymore or that he has no idea what
cliff is talking about um
is so this is why cliff instantly cuts
to the chase with howard um and denying
what cliffs what cliff believes is the
truth will just make him further not
believe howard's defense and that's why
he says i just want you to know that i
know because you know
regardless of all the excuses that he
thinks that howard is giving him
i want you to know that i know and
i i just think that i think it's kind of
hilarious the way that howard just cuts
cliff off and totally disregards his
accusations and concerns from here on
out leaving abruptly because you know
initially cliff wouldn't tell him that
he met with kim or that he met with the
kettleman's but when he finally lets it
slip that he was with kim when he saw
the whole wendy's scheme howard puts two
and two together and and i i really love
the ending line here he has a problem
but it's not what cliff thinks he
doesn't have a drug problem he has a
mcgill problem and
i don't know i it's just the second that
he hears kim's name he he just puts the
clues together and he's like all right
i'm not dealing with this conversation i
gotta go take care of something like
peace out so i don't know i really like
that confrontation i was waiting for it
for a few episodes ever since they
started setting up cliff with all of
this and uh yeah i think it was a really
great scene
gill
yeah it's one of those things that
i i i saw a lot of comments where people
enjoyed this episode even less than last
week's and last week's was pretty
controversial just because i think
people are so antsy
for the big plot things to move forward
i think a big part of whether or not
this episode will work for you is how
much
you could enjoy being in the moment for
some of these scenes because we all knew
this confrontation was coming this is
kind of the punch line to the setup from
the last few episodes
going all the way back to cliff seeing
the drugs fall out of howard's locker we
knew at some point he would reach a
boiling point in his suspicions and we
see that here
and for me
it was a ton of fun because you realize
how brilliant the setup is it's the
power of reframing
when you look at howard you see him as a
really motivated energetic guy but as
soon as someone says cocaine to you you
see yeah he is a really energetic guy
and now you're seeing it through cliff's
eyes and seeing how nervous cliff looks
in that sandpiper scene how scared he is
when howard stands up to take control of
the meeting roy that he's gonna totally
mess everything up i was laughing i was
laughing throughout the entire sequence
i was laughing at the confrontation
so
we all knew it was coming but i i just
thought it pulled off so it's such a
viscerally enjoyable way
and now we're at that point we are now
at the point where howard knows jimmy
and kim are behind this and now it
starts to progress so so i kind of loved
all of it
yeah and i don't have a whole lot to add
at this at this juncture you guys went
through most of it but i think that one
it was really good to see um
it was really good to see howard in his
in all of his glory you know standing up
there and selling the idea
like that you pointed out chase that
these are people who don't have a lot of
time to wait and he's selling them the
idea of waiting you know that it's the
right thing to do and
also what you were saying gil like the
the as soon as i saw um
ed egg begley i mentioned it earlier ed
begley jr does such a good job in this
in this i really enjoyed cliff main in a
way that i never had before in this
episode and
when he started seeing the leg
bouncing you know you know it's coming
you know he's gonna have to uh you know
get this stuff off of his chest
so i thought they handled that really
well and you know obviously the fact
that he has a history with his own
family and
you know he's inclined not to believe
whatever howard tells him
and then i really thought that the
howard line you know cancel my week um
you know he just sort of he he first is
howard hamlin to the core he says i know
this was hard for you thank for thank
you for coming to me as a friend but
then he just goes and he's just like
clear my week and now i'm gonna fight
you know it was the it was the change
that we've all been kind of waiting for
from from howard uh and it's great that
it finally
is upon us and uh really quickly
whisper gaming
thank you for that when jimmy and kim
get married the judge paused when he
said her name
do you think that's just a slip or a
blip
or something more sinister i don't know
people uh people have
brought this up as like that that might
be a
you know part of her changing her name
i i don't think that that's a lock it is
interesting that they that they stop on
it that they kind of they kind of
mention it but like if you were gonna
change your name why would you not add a
middle name if that was you know such a
big deal so i don't i don't put a lot of
stock in it either of you guys
um i mean well
it is kind of a theory floating out
there in the wind about maybe kim has
already changed her name like maybe they
get to disappear because she already has
that connection but
i'm pretty sure that during the kim
flashback to her as a kid with her mom
drunk driving pretty sure her mom does
call her kim so unless she just changed
her last name or or something like that
i don't know i mean some people do just
not have middle names
honestly nothing to add for me i feel
like i need to re-watch that scene to
see what people are referencing here
but i'll just say
i'm going to bow out at this time so i
just want to say this was awesome and i
want to thank everybody for
participating and i mean all the kind
comments they they really make i've had
some bad days where a nice comment is
the thing that turns it around so we
definitely appreciate everybody
getting involved to make this live
stream so much fun so thank you pete for
having me on and i'll talk to you again
next week and also vivid kiwi chase
great to meet you yeah yeah yeah it was
great talking man i really enjoyed this
convo and uh yeah big big fan of your uh
your saw cast too i check that out when
i can so i love the stuff you're doing
over there
awesome thanks man
yeah
once again yo we'll see you next week
and um i'll talk to you before that
sounds good being here take care
everyone
yep
okay and so we have one other quick one
here robert lukowski 199. thank you for
that ice station zebra is kim receiving
alimony
uh that's a statement um
you know it could be the truth uh it
doesn't feel like it's going in that
direction right at this moment but
who knows uh you have anything you want
to add to that
um
i mean about a year ago i did a full
lifestation zebra theory explained the
two moments that uh piqued my interest
are the fact that kim is the one that
shows jimmy the ice station zebra movie
i think her father
really liked the movie or something and
then um
just the whole walt and skylar what is
ice station zebra oh and that's the
thing that actually gets walt to
introduce skylar to saul so i think that
either one it is kim or two saul just
names it that in memory of kim
yeah and they've had the ice station
zebra check up on the mirror in their
apartment ever since they they got that
you know after they watch this the movie
together so it you know it's a name that
it's a co it's it's common to the to
their you know to their whole experience
i don't think it's a hundred percent
like oh well he named his company that
so that means that that kim is still
involved you know i mean it's a it's a
chance to
uh i mean
that that could be a hint but it might
not be either um
so i guess be that he misses her you
know
yeah that's what i'm saying like there's
a there's a lot of stuff like that in
their story
so uh do we have anything else i i just
wanted to say one other thing like
there's a moment in that in the
with ed begley jr where he's uh he
thinks that
he's making a breakthrough with um
with howard about you know you can just
it's not it's no problem to ask for help
and and howard does that but then he you
know he changes it up he says that his
problem isn't drugs it's it's jimmy but
there's there's this scene where he's
like he's like so overjoyed that this is
coming up and then he just sort of drops
and uh
i really thought that was was a great
exchange between those two actors
do you have anything else that you want
to add on the howard stuff before we
move on
uh no i'm pretty good to move on
honestly i said most my opinions just
yeah i really like the scene and
and i i really do love how just the
second that you know cliff mentions kim
it just suddenly all makes sense and all
of how our stress goes away and it it
goes from confusing confusion and stress
and almost anxiety and to just just
anger towards jimmy and kim he's just
fed up with it because he already tried
confronting jimmy in season five and the
thing is about the wendy scheme is it
relates back to jimmy sending uh sex
workers to
their lunch because cliff was with
howard in season five when that happened
so this is probably why cliff thinks
that you know it's been going on for a
while
yeah and we'll come back to that when we
get into the fight because that really
comes you know that's not just that that
actually comes out into
it clears the air about some of that
stuff so
to go really quickly before we go there
jimmy does establish his office at the
strip mall in this episode we touched on
a little bit i don't think we need to
linger too much but uh it was nice to
see francesca's return
and um
i don't know why but the the music drop
here like you know the her listening to
wilson phillips when she pulled up that
just seemed hilarious to me like to the
point where i was like wait a minute
that's not even a contemporary song
right that's that's much older and i had
to look it up and found out that it was
like
15 years old by the time that she's
she's rocking it in the strip mall
parking lot there
i i the only thing that i would add i
mean obviously it's fun to see jimmy and
you know bob odenkirk kind of
portraying the character as saul
you know like you see that sipping like
seeping in my opinion you see that
seeping into the performance more
but um
francesca you know i i wonder because we
always have kind of thought of her as
she was this really nice person from the
mvd that they meet back in season two
and then you know she she comes back
later and just gets ground down by this
life as being connected to
saul and being in around him but here it
kind of makes it feel like she's more of
a willing participant she just needs to
be she just needs the right incentives
you know
yeah
yeah yeah she definitely just needs to
be coerced i mean you know he gives he
gives her the whole like you know
sanders is to chicken goodman is to the
law and
you know as convincing as that whole
speech was like she definitely just
needed some cold hard cash in order to
be convinced and same thing with the the
405 flash forward right like she just
kind of gives them the look that you
know give me another kind of kind of wad
of cash here and
it is kind of a de-evolution of the
character just like all the characters
on the show because she is all sweet and
innocent in season three but then i was
actually just re-watching the last few
episodes of season four breaking bad and
the moment where uh walt breaks through
the door and is like oh saul i need him
now and then francesca just starts
starts you know giving him the business
and and in order to for her to tell him
where saul is she's like oh i think that
that window's gonna cost uh 20 000. he's
like what what and then and once he
finally realizes what's going on she's
like uh 25. so you know she
is she she is built of some sterner
stuff herself that's for sure i'm really
glad to see her back on the show been
waiting for her return for quite a while
now i'm really glad she's back in the
fold and i can't wait to see uh what
more comes from her
yeah yeah that's what i thought that you
know that
she was she was getting ready to leave
until he mentioned the money
and i thought that that stood out
because of those scenes you're talking
about where she does that she sort of
you know she was sort of uh
she was kind of low-key like not really
just she was just sort of there and then
whenever money came up she was like you
know like that scene you're talking
about and the quite a quite a ride one
you know where she's just like you got
to give me more money
uh whisper gaming 4.99 howard's so
interesting and who's his wife the woman
jesse was with in
season one episode one of breaking bad
just kidding mostly
so yeah we don't really know much about
his wife um
but i but i hope we do learn a little
bit more i like i i just had a uh i made
a video about why they were going after
howard
and um
you know that was one of the things is
that he's
he's he's always been around but they
never really fleshed him out
and um you know that now that he's he's
kind of locked in this situation with
them
it'll be interesting to see what more we
learn about him as they go on and one
thing i learned about making that video
is that people that like him who maybe
think that you know people don't give
him a fair shake because
he was born into it man they come out of
the woodwork whenever you try to uh
discredit him in any way
definitely definitely got some howard
stands that's for sure i mean i do like
the guy you know ever since it turns out
that he's not darth vader and chuck is
and he's just his puppet like did gain a
lot of sympathy for him and i realized
you know he's not really that bad of a
guy but you know he is still a little
bit of a prick i mean i am a huge howard
fan i wish the best for him i feel
really bad for him but you know i'm not
not gonna you know you know be stand
alone on that island and just praise him
because you know he he does have
different sides to him i mean
and
i don't know i don't know man that's
that's just the thing
yeah he's a complicated character and
he's a good character that i enjoy
watching um people i think some people
like you know they got kind of defensive
and and really just you know
about a fictional character and what
these characters are doing you know like
what their reasoning is not what
is morally correct or what i think
personally which i just found it kind of
funny
but you know talking of howard we we do
get to see this fight and um
yeah i
i i don't know like i to me
it it was awkward it was purpose of it
was like a purpose purposefully awkward
situation because
this is too like
older men who aren't necessarily
training or in shape and
those kinds of fights aren't really that
glamorous you know like when i was
making the video i just kind of thought
that there's the way that howard sees
this like you know he's gonna he's gonna
um
you know do this man to man he's going
to give jimmy a chance to to fight it
out with him and it's going to be
dramatic but the way it looks is is this
kind of pathetic so what were you what
was your take on the actual fight like
the mechanics of the fight playing out i
mean so we've kind of seen it teased in
trailers since before season six started
but i didn't actually think that they'd
be fighting each other like i thought
maybe uh maybe howard was betting on a
fight or maybe he was in a fight himself
but that jimmy it was going to be one of
his schemes to kind of rig the match
against howard or in his own favor and i
thought it was going to be i thought he
was going to mess with a boxing fight i
i wasn't sure
that they were actually going to fight
themselves and then you know you see
jimmy start to walk away
and then he caves in and they fight and
and that that did genuinely get me hyped
because you know i wasn't really
expecting it you know i thought jimmy
was just gonna be like ha ha funny jokes
and walk away but
and the way that he does walk away and
then stop for a moment and then he goes
back it reminds me of in uh episode 601
where he's at the clubhouse and he kind
of gets told no and then he starts
walking away and then he thinks for a
minute and then he goes back and
purposely starts that argument with
kevin so it's just sort of him giving in
when he knows that he shouldn't
and yeah it was
it was a purposely uh sloppy fight um
i i do think that they just kind of
haphazardly fight each other as you know
jimmy in particular stumbles around the
rig obvious ring obviously not knowing
proper former punches it's one point
where you think jimmy's gonna quick he
comes back full force and just tackles
howard which
okay sure you know and uh you know jimmy
does get one good punch in but howard
retaliates with that double combo giving
jimmy you know the i think it was a
sucker punch or a hook and then and then
that uppercut to finish him off i mean i
i tweeted about that that uppercut just
made my jaw drop like i'm not entirely
surprised that howard won but still
can't believe it happened i definitely
would have paid good money to see this
fight in person not gonna lie
yeah i didn't think it was gonna happen
either and um you know i could it it
wasn't i think it was it was you know
the intention was for it to be funny i
didn't find it funny in the same way
that um
that i did like say the the opening
sequence where they impersonated him and
stole his car in the in the last episode
i thought it i thought it paled in in
comparison there
but like i said i did like the idea of
of just you know his frustration like
howard is what what what can howard do i
mean like they're literally doing like
pranks you know what i mean from his
perspective
like pranks that he can't do anything
about but they have actual you know
they have repercussions for his career
and everything else so it's it's
terribly annoying
and so he he resorts to the pi which is
i think is probably is pretty
fascinating because of the fact that
mike already has guys following them
because of wallet
and there's some real potential for
crossover there where things could get
dark and bring howard into the other
side which he doesn't have any there's
no other way for that to happen really
the way he lives his life
you know he he just wouldn't get sucked
into that if kim and jimmy weren't doing
these these schemes and trying to force
this sandpiper settlement so there's
some there's some real stakes there do
you have anything that you want to add
to that
yeah actually i believe there was a
super chat that mentioned the pi earlier
and i was kind of butting my tongue a
little bit just specifically for this
moment
because you are kind of right you know
like what can howard do like he's just
gonna try and let jimmy blow up some
steam and that's it but you know after
he goes and talks to the pi it's kind of
revealed that the fight wasn't just to
box jimmy it was actually a bit of a
misdirect and uh distraction because
after the fight he goes to the pi you
know hires them says he wants them to
follow uh jimmy
and and the thing is we were suspecting
that howard would hire a pi against
jimmy and kim for a while and and the
most popular theory of who was following
jimmy and kim at the end of 602 was that
howard got a pi so it was surprising
that it was actually mike's men but now
we finally get to that point where
howard's fighting back he's hired a pi
happened you know two second or two
episodes later than we thought but uh
yeah this could be very dangerous
because
just who knows when lalo will return or
any other cartel member that might want
to work with jimmy or have him defend
them legally you know i'm definitely
worried that howard's p.i may find some
sort of cartel connection with jimmy and
kim causing howard to get involved with
the cartel side of things it's no secret
anymore that you know jimmy represented
lalo so howard may want to look further
into it and so howard and his pi
sneaking around being nosy towards jimmy
and kim might result in the pi being
killed or even howard too or at least
kidnapped and scared to death and um to
bring up another point that you made
real quick um since mike's men are
following jimmy and kim around will they
have some sort of conflict of interest
in regards to howard's pi too because
now we do have two separate groups or
parties trying to follow around and
track kim and jimmy so i i wonder if
they will clash at all
yeah
i think it's you know that i saw a lot
of other people bringing that up in the
comments in my video that they were
thinking the same thing so it's it's i
think we're supposed to be thinking that
and it makes you worry a little bit
about howard and his safety like you
said
um then then they go back home jimmy
comes back home and there's a nice shot
where kim
smiles when she sees and pull up just to
remind you that they are in love
regardless of whatever else is going on
and then that sort of drops whenever she
sees that he has an ice pack on his head
and
they um
we kind of touched on on the the thing
from viola already uh i do think that
there's a possibility that they're going
to be impersonating that judge at some
point
based on what they said there about the
uh handlebar mustache
and um but more i think what the big
part of all this was is that they
weren't
at all
you know there was no like oh my god
howard figured this out like it was it
was completely part of their plan and
that's what i had been saying from the
beginning like from the moment that i
watched the first trailer
it didn't make sense to me that they
could because back then you thought that
that um howard was going to be
building a case against them and none of
that made sense because
you know
these guys are good at running scams you
know they're they're not going to
give him an open and so then i thought
the natural thing must be that
they that's part of their plan and we
see that that's true
but we have no idea what their plan is
or what they're planning on doing with
that and i think that's another place
where this gets a little frustrating for
me
there's like you know the there's like a
mystery of what's gonna happen and
you're gonna have um
you're going to have good reveals and
and payoff to those things and that
that'll all make sense later
but then there's also the thing of just
not i'm just kind of feeling a little
bit confused and i i do feel a little
bit confused about um you know after
seeing them in bed together
jimmy is kind of the audience proxy
there because he's confused he doesn't
know why he fought howard
kim feels completely certain that that
he does and i guess it's because she
feels like he's guilty he feels guilty
about what they're about to do
but you know at the same time we don't
know what what they're going to do they
like just she does and she feels
confident about it but
we might have to wait an episode or two
to find out
yeah well that's that's a really good
point and that's an interesting
perspective like i now i am wondering
like did they always intend on howard
finding out eventually um because the
the thing is with saul goodman and jamie
mcgill and slipping jimmy like his whole
life like
everyone knows what he's doing but you
know that bill oakley line you know
there's there's proving it and then
there's knowing it everyone knows but
it's just trying to prove it you know
jimmy always gets away with it so i and
yeah they don't really seem shocked that
he's on to them they're like all right
cool let's just continue on with
screwing with them
yeah i do think it's i think that um
it's definitely part of their their plan
and uh i guess that's really
the main thing
the main points about everything in the
united states and i think we can now
shift over to
germany
and but first i guess we should we
should touch on the teaser you guys
mentioned it earlier um i don't think i
chimed in really i i do i did like this
i i didn't know what was going on
i did think about
verner right away whenever i saw the
slide rule
you know well not maybe right away but
as i went through list of characters
that this might be connected to you know
that was the one that that that landed
on
so i thought that was it was was pretty
satisfying but it was also mysterious
and like i said you get trained when you
watch
breaking bad and better call saul that
if they introduce something there will
be a payoff and they did the same thing
with the piece of glass in episode three
and
yeah and i i appreciate that i like feeling
like i'm on the inside of you know like
i'm on i'm like i'm in on on the uh
the inside of the story that they're
telling or whatever you know that we
have this uh this thing going this
connection going on with with what's
happening
um as far as the the thing with with
germany like i said i i
i couldn't imagine that he was anywhere
else so it was just a matter of time of
revealing that
but i also wasn't ready for how how off
like how
how they put it together like it was
actually pretty satisfying to see him
come up to her at the bar i mentioned
his american accent him pulling that out
that was it was really spot-on
and
gil was talking about how they built her
up pretty um pretty effortlessly because
of what we know about her from her
husband
and yeah i mean i just felt like i was
right there and this if you watch this
out of context if you didn't know what
was going on that this could have been
any kind of
you know romantic uh
you know uh meeting in in a movie or
whatever and i kind of think because my
wife watches a lot of korean tv and um
every once in a while i'll see and
she'll be watching some kind of k drama
or something oh yeah it kind of it kind
of felt like that it could have just
been something that i could have seen in
the screen looking over his shoulder
like that you know i mean
what do you got about what
what do you thought about
about germany
uh so so real quick about the
about the intro or the teaser i do want
to say that the whole german song
playing the during the cold open uh i
believe the name of the song is in still
or knocked and uh the german track is
the first hint on what happens uh and
what what the plaque is about along with
uh the
uh you know i don't i don't speak german
but i in liebe
dain jongs which is translates roughly
to with love your boys and so
you know i
i was like are they really doing this
are they really going to go there are we
actually going to see something more
that involves werner and and that's
that's exactly what happened and
i was i was in i was almost in denial
when i first you know i saw the arcade
machine in germany and or in german you
know letters and and then and then we
see werner's wife there or you know
widow and um
i i don't know when we first saw that i
was just in shock and denial i'd you
know i had no clue this was gonna happen
so when it did i was really surprised
and i gotta say lala must have done some
research in order to find out where she
would be i don't know exactly what could
have put a tracker on her car but you
know we assumed that she didn't know he
didn't know where she lived until he
walked her home so how did he do that
did he just i don't know i don't know
what kind of research he could have done
i feel like that might be a bit of a bit
of a plot hole but again the show just
tends to not focus on things that may
not be particularly important just like
how we didn't necessarily see nacho get
smuggled back to albuquerque we just
kind of saw him get out of the truck so
um but but in in regards to werner's
wife i mean back in the season four
finale considering that werner had to
kind of act like an ass to her for their
final conversation in order to stop her
from coming to america saved her life
but it made her almost essentially hate
him like she'll never know how much he
truly cared for her in his final moments
you know he he made her think that he
only cared about his work instead of her
so
so that already kind of broke my heart
like i was really depressed from uh
werner's fate in the season four finales
so
not to return to that with the the
werner story arc but show more
elaboration on how distraught the wife
is due to the mysterious and isolating
circumstances it really is heartbreaking
i think the the actor that played a i
think her name's marguer marguerite or
something like that i think i think
yeah i think she did an amazing job i
really felt for her but you know that
being said wow did uh lalo ever put the
moves on her he's just so
devilishly charismatic he knows how to
play that part of a true gentleman with
manners and and that's the thing like
he's so charismatic that's why he brings
new life to the show because this is a
skill trade that i don't think we've
ever seen from any other salamanca it
it's deadly both metaphorically and
sometimes literally but
you know you know twitter was going
crazy a little bit thirsty for lala last
night i just can't believe that lalo
almost slept with her and on the other
hand you know their conversation was
believable and incredibly smooth so you
know as you're saying if you saw this
out of context then you'd totally
believe that this was naturally
happening you know it made sense that it
could be a possibility
yeah and i i tell you like you know the
the the way that we've been
the way that we've been kind of trained
to see that whenever his whenever he's
at his most charismatic that they remind
us how brutal he can actually be
that was where that like i didn't feel a
lot of tension as far as marguerite like
i didn't really it didn't really dawn on
me that her dying would
improve the story at all and then if you
think about it some more then you think
like well okay uh
if he did do that like gus is probably
still paying keeping tabs on her so that
might even come back on him because he
doesn't know that gus thinks that he's
still alive so her dying you know or
disappearing would definitely
be like you know on his radar or
whatever where i was where i was was was
really worried was about the dog like i
thought for sure that he was going to
kill this dog i don't know like when
when he came up
and he's getting ready to le you know
she says oh yeah just me and the dog you
know and so it was totally there on the
radar
and then he comes in and i'm like oh man
if he kills this dog like you know i
love this character i'll enjoy the
character either way but this is gonna
like you know he he killed someone in
the beginning of
the first uh episode
to burn his body you know as a body
double but like i i really couldn't
abide the dog um if he was gonna go that
far
so i thought that was a funny way that
they that they kind of uh skirted around
that you know added a little bit of
weird tension there
you know
i don't know
oh yeah i was i was just gonna elaborate
on the dog like i i feel like uh i think
the name of the dog was little bear um
yeah it was was really a surprise star
in this episode i mean everyone loves
the dog right and just kind of kind of
doing that cliche where you kill the dog
on a show i mean like i'm about to cry
more than hey you know then how
depressed i was about about nacho um i i
do think that little bear lives up to
his name you know alerting marguerite
that lala was there by barking his
little head off um i do love the way
that lalo just kind of talks to the cute
pupper like he kind of gives his puppy
dog voice to him like you should be
quiet um i really did like that moment i
didn't really think that he was going to
kill the dog but when the dog wouldn't
start bark stop barking i mean like
you know big big yikes it was definitely
a thought that went through my head
yeah in my video i was just saying how
you know it
i was i was relieved to find out that
his charms you know extend to the animal
kingdom right like he can he can charm
people but he can also uh charm beast
whenever it's necessary even in like a
foreign language so that was a pretty
that was a pretty cool thing it kind of
makes it even more of a legend i guess
you know yeah i saw i saw a tweet
calling lalo a dog whisperer so i
thought that was pretty funny yeah that
makes sense and so while he's there you
know she comes back anyway he you know
he he he was going to go in with her at
night he she doesn't invite him in so he
just basically lurks in her neighborhood
until morning and he sees her leave
he sneaks in we already talked about his
encounter with the dog and then
she comes back and um
what i liked about this again i didn't
really think that he was going to kill
her like it that there was tension in
that he's there's going to be a
confrontation
it wasn't really about her dying so much
but then what i really liked about that
is how they mixed in him figuring out
this
this thing is important the slide rule
is important
and you know you're watching and
you put it together almost in the same
amount of time that he does or or i
guess
if you're you know if you were
distracted by something else then you
put it together after the scene is over
because there's only one real reason why
that would make sense it ties back to
the teaser they so they showed that
being made we know it was made somewhere
we know someone bought it so that him
seeing the the name of that underneath
means that he's going to go find out who
commissioned this thing
and that's going to lead him closer to
what gus was doing under the laundry
yeah yeah i agree completely so um
i don't know i i definitely think that
you know he looks at it because he sees
the manufacturer he's gonna go to the
manufacturer and ask who the names of
who uh who ordered it and then that's
how he's going to get to kai and the
others and then he's going to
interrogate them so i mean he really
could leave a blood trail throughout
throughout this whole thing you know he
could have killed marguerite he could
kill the manufacturer he could kill kai
but i mean i feel like he only kills
when he really needs to and
i mean
just the fact that werner's wife didn't
know verner's men you know lala takes
things into his own hands literally by
grabbing the plaque
i i don't know like i'm just trying to
think for a second here because a gus
probably threatened uh werner's workers
to never have contact with werner's
family again or else gus would have
killed them too which is which is why
they never met werner's wife or why they
never went to the funeral and just those
little things also really pull out my
heart strings this is why i really care
for the wife here
yeah i think that that was the
implication of that like i don't see why
you would i mean obviously they built up
this whole you know symbol that they
mailed to her and that's going to end up
going against them but that was what i
interpreted that like the whole part of
him bringing that up at the bar
was that we're supposed to know that you
know mike and gus threatened them not to
go around her you know i mean because
that way they can't she can't ask them
questions about what happened
yeah so another thing once uh marguerite
got home i realized that we were about
to see the clips from the trailers i
know i mentioned trailer clips too much
but but of lalo sneaking around the
house with a silenced pistol i can't
believe this whole time those trailer
clips were lollow in verner's house it
it blew my mind it it made the situation
even more tense before it even truly
started then when she started creeping
around her house with lala waiting for
her my my heart was genuinely pounding i
was ready to yell and shout at the sight
of lalo killing her thankfully that
didn't happen i mean i i really do i
really do care for her in this moment
and just for someone that we're seeing
on screen for the first time it's
amazing how these show creators get me
to care so much and feel so much about
such a realistically insignificant
character i mean it was just it was just
beautifully done and there was a moment
when lala was hiding in the house i
think you know around the time he puts
on the silencer he almost had a look of
sadness before he mentally realizes and
decides that he might have to kill her
if she discovers him because as much of
a brutal killer that lalo is he did seem
to genuinely enjoy his time with her and
and he cares for her i mean maybe that's
why he didn't want you know try to go in
and sleep with her because he knew that
he had other intel other intentions or
whatever and so it's enough that he's
using her you know you don't you know
don't want to just do that too so i mean
i feel like he kind of respects her a
little bit um
and so you know he sneaks out the window
to try to escape when normally he might
have just killed her like he killed the
travel wire employee but and also
emotions aside i mean i did say that he
could just leave a bloodbath in his wake
but it's possibly true that he didn't
kill her or the dog in order to not
raise suspicions maybe back to gus
learning that werner's wife was murdered
yeah
yeah i think you know that that
like i said i think it would make sense
for him to be keeping tabs on her
so right now lalo's advantage is that
gus thinks he's dead
we know we know that he doesn't think
he's dead but as far as lalo is
concerned he does you know what i mean
so
it would blow his advantage that he has
by blowing up the idea that he's still
around
and earlier in the stream i think you
are right in regards to thinking about
the
the uh spicy curls in regards to
thinking about magic madrigal and the
german connection like if he's already
thinking about germany and then he hears
that werner's wife was you know suddenly
murdered you know he that that might be
all of the validation and update that he
needs that that that lollows on to him
about the south wall
yeah and and i think that you know like
you what you were saying there that
there is something to that about him not
wanting to kill her even though all the
other things make sense too
um they do they do allude to that a
little bit on the insider podcast um
uh the uh i think it was
uh alison
tutlock as that was that was the who
wrote this episode
um
she says something about it and uh
they wanted to make that that they
wanted to make that interaction at the
bar their meeting and their and their
connection they wanted that to be
to actually be real you know what i mean
like that they really did
he wasn't just completely um
fooling her you know i mean like that
they had like a genuine they had a
genuine kind of chemistry there and that
they they they were interested in each
other at least you know what i mean
yeah like as they said right in another
life i really do feel like lalo does
respect her and and kind of cares about
her through that interaction
and you know that's that's pretty much
where things are left um
you know that i thought i did like the
touch of where she closes the window and
it's kind of a mirror image of the of
the opening of the episode in the
beginning of the teaser the uh
the technician opens the cabinet before
he makes the um lucite uh slide rule
thing
uh you know we're we're getting up to
almost three hours here and i i can't i
can't stay on indefinitely um
yeah sadly i know right
yeah uh i do
there's a couple of things i guess
i i don't have like a an actual time
when i have to leave i'm supposed to be
somewhere in 40 minutes but
that's kind of beside the point at the
moment um
the the i guess what i guess the reason
that we we were talking about this and
where we decided you would come on today
was that we had a little bit of a
differing opinion as far as as uh you
know
our our our feelings on the episode like
i said i i pretty much made mine clear
over here
the idea that we're behind characters in
their planning that's kind of grating on
me a little bit
the low stakes involved in gus i think
that that's just kind of dragged on a
little bit too long with him being
paranoid and um
and then i just think that the fight and
and some of the other stuff didn't hit
it wasn't as entertaining for me as as
episode the stuff that they similar
stuff that they did in the similarly
paced episode four
so i guess i'll give you a moment if you
want to talk about the things that you
really liked about it
before we we move on
yeah yeah so
so i mean first off there are a few
things that i that i do agree with like
i do i do see your points um
i think that in episode 604 like we're
wondering where lalo is and the
characters are wondering just as much so
that really ramps up the anxiety and
then finally we see where lalo is at the
end of this episode but because it's at
the end of the episode we still had the
whole episode of gus still pretty much
in that same state and i do kind of wish
that maybe they did something more with
that side of the story but again it is
it is jimmy jimmy and kim's story mainly
so i really enjoyed everything that went
on i honestly wasn't wasn't bored at all
this episode like if you go back and
look at all my tweets i'm just i'm just
spamming a bunch of live tweets all my
thoughts during the commercial breaks i
really did enjoy this episode a lot more
than than 604 and yeah that's that's why
i also thought that this conversation
was going to be really interesting
because
i didn't really like 604 you did and
then i like 605 and it seems that you
know you you don't so much so it feels
like we almost have a flip-flop there so
so it's really interesting to you know
hear your hear your perspective and hear
gil's perspective and uh
and uh i'm just i'm just glad i was able
to show my or share my opinions of this
episode because from the i mean i just
really really like francesca's character
i i think you know she she has some
balls i i'm glad that she's back on the
show i've been waiting for that for a
long time i've been been waiting for the
cliff and howard confrontation for a
long time we were predicting the howard
pi thing for a long time i just feel
like it's a lot of you know we finally
get lalo this episode i i feel like
there's just a lot of payoff and it's
like yes this is what i was waiting to
see so i'm really i'm really glad you
know with the way this episode turned
out and um
and i'll definitely have to listen to
the insider podcast um i i'm probably
gonna listen to you tonight honestly
later on when i have some spare time
uh but yeah i don't know i just really
enjoyed this episode i i'm glad that i'm
glad that we got to see lalo finally and
along with all the other things that i
just said i'm just i feel like it was
even though you know some people think
it's a building episode which it you
know kind of is
uh and that now lalo is hopefully i mean
you think we're gonna get another full
episode of lalo in germany you know
trying to talk to the manufacturer and
talk to kai or or do you think maybe he
could you know that'd be like you know
the first half of his story for an
episode and then the second half like
maybe we actually will see him return
because i kind of hope that we see him
back in albuquerque you know by next
episode i i don't want it to just be the
mid-season finale where we kind of get a
get a standoff i really hope that the
wheels turn
uh next episode leading into the
mid-season finale um but yeah i'm just i
don't know i don't know i really like
this episode i think it's a really
strong one
yeah i i don't really know um they don't
even i think that they set it up good
enough that they don't even have to show
him going to the to the place that made
the the um
like i would be okay with it if he just
showed up at kai's wherever kai is or or
whoever he goes to see you know what i
mean yeah we could put that together to
speed that up a little bit but there is
a step there's an actual step you know
he has to do something before he could
head back
to look for the proof so
you're you're right about that that this
might he might not be in the mix in new
mexico next episode either
so what does that mean for what's going
on with gus you know what i mean
are we going to get a third episode of
him being paranoid with anxious ocd i i
mean
what else what else could he possibly do
is he going to have just kind of a
mental breakdown like i already kind of
had that with the toothbrush right so i
don't know
yeah we'll see where they go with that
and um you know i i think i i watched
the i watched the teaser it it
it looks like there's some some
interesting stuff coming um you know i i
don't have any like whenever i i i saw a
lot of people because i was i was
somewhat critical of it whenever i was
talking about it then i see a lot of
people that are like
you know they're they're they're they're
they're thinking they're in agreement by
saying that it's a filler episode or
it's the worst of the season or i hate
it you know like and that's not really
the position i'm coming from i didn't
find it as satisfying as as some of the
other episodes is more of it i mean i i
definitely feel like that the writers
have
earned um
the benefit of the doubt you know like i
remember season four there was a lot of
people who were upset
with uh some of the way things were
playing out i know some people who
stopped watching it at the end of season
four
and i remember in season five people
were complaining about the pace in in
the early going and look how that turned
out you know what i mean and you know i
i have i i thought that the show was
pretty indulgent in the first couple of
seasons in that in that regard as well
and i've said that
so you know
i'm glad that they did what they did
because now
the way that
you know the way that things are playing
out you know everything
everything matters you know what i mean
and i think the character development is
what what sets this this show apart from
from lesser shows
but i didn't i didn't really this one
didn't have as much of that i didn't
think as as as 604 did
i mean like so first off about about
season four um you know there's some
things that i just don't don't remember
about it i feel like it's my most
forgettable season of the show and
honestly it might be my least favorite
like i'm kind of a bit nervous for when
i do my season for a tier list because
there are a lot of good moments like the
shootout with nacho and the twins arturo
covering that up the breaking bad flash
forward but
i
i feel like that season did kind of drag
a bit and the thing about episode 604
it's not that i don't like the episode
you know it it just it just feels like a
normal better call saul episode it feels
like something we would have seen in
season four season two
and you know not every single episode
needs to be this crazy you know with
with lalo and the twins and all of that
or sorry nacho and the twins you know
not every episode needs to be crazy we
can't have building episodes and in a
way that is what 605 is but i just feel
like 605 is worthy of being a final
season episode and 604 just kind of
feels like a normal episode which again
isn't bad like i still like normal
better cost all episodes but it just
feels like you know something we would
have seen in season two and not
necessarily you know
final season material
yeah it's one of the weird things
whenever we when we look at each one
individually
you know they all become a part of they
all become a part of a whole
and season four was was a pretty good
example of that where
um there were times when i wasn't sure
what they were doing and i didn't really
understand that we that we were supposed
to be kind of feeling that way because
that's how jimmy was feeling and you
know it took a little while but when i
go back and re-watch it now
i don't i don't have that same
experience i i love it like it's a it's
a really great uh you know it's really a
great journey for the character
and so you know like that's one of like
when you just were talking about
individual episodes they they
you know some are going to some are
going to be more
pleasing at the moment than others but
they're all part of a whole so it's kind
of a it's kind of a wasted um
endeavor anyways you know what i mean
yeah and that might be another thing
about uh possible complaints about the
last two episodes in regards to the pace
because i mean i i saw a comment in the
chat like you know the show has always
had that sort of pace and maybe it's
just the fact that you know i have
noticed that a lot of people are jumping
on board for the final season a better
call saul in in a similar way that a lot
of people jumped on to the final season
of breaking bad and just people are
maybe you know i don't want to assume
things but kind of am i just feel like
maybe people are used to binging the
whole show so just having to wait week
to week now is just a little bit more
strenuous you know you kind of want more
to happen and sometimes you don't get it
but that being said um this episode was
a little bit extended because normally
the episodes are around 42 to 46 minutes
long and and this one clocked in i think
51 52 minutes like uh i was watching it
live on tv and it went past the hour
mark like i think it was 15 minutes into
the next hour now obviously that's
including commercials but usually a show
will end exactly at that hour mark so
including commercials it was like 15
minutes extra not counting commercials
it was you know probably like five to
ten five seven minutes extra uh they
actually did the same thing with episode
602 as well during the double premiere i
mean uh the end of 602 was was you know
about 15 minutes into the third hour so
you know that's why 601 and 602 almost
felt like a mini better call saw movie
that i almost enjoy more than el camino
um i i really do like how they extend
some of these episodes they only they
only make them as long as they feel like
they need to like i think 604 was a
little bit shorter at like 42 minutes
instead of the usual 46
but uh yeah i don't know it's it's
always always a little bit of a treat
when you go past the hour mark can you
realize the episode's not over yet
yeah and um you know
speaking of time i do think that i'm
gonna have to wrap this up
uh it's always weird uh last week
i was in here by myself and there was
still more than 600 people and it feels
weird to shut it down but um
three hours is kind of is kind of like
where i think i start to lose my
focus on what's happening and um yeah
i do have an appointment in 30 minutes
that i have to make and it's going to
take a little bit of time to get ready
for that so
i don't know where i just uh i i'll just
say thanks to everyone who showed up we
hit a thousand this week that was uh
that was
really cool um i absolutely kind of been
going up each week and that's a nice
thing to see
um i really enjoy getting to do that so
thank you to you guys for coming in and
asking questions and
gill's already gone but i'll thank you
again chase for coming in and giving me
a chance to talk a little bit more in
depth and get different perspectives
because you know whenever i i enjoy
making
you know the recaps and and doing it
that way but it's it limits the uh what
you can do and the time constraints and
and just editing you know we always talk
about this stuff when we were talking
behind the scenes or whatever you know
what i mean
it's pretty great that you can sit here
and talk about this for three hours and
people will show up and be engaged so i
feel pretty lucky and pretty thankful
for that you got anything yeah you can
plug your stuff before we go
yeah for sure i just wanted to say you
know of course thanks for having me on i
really appreciate it this was really a
lot of fun those three hours just just
flew by and it was also you know with
the help of all the super chats and all
the interesting questions it really got
my brain spinning about better call saul
and just as you were saying you know
being able to just openly discuss all of
your thoughts not having to worry about
oh this video is going to take forever
to edit i'm not i'm not too familiar
with live streams i've never done any on
my channel personally you know that
options always open in the future but uh
i really enjoyed this the the three
hours just just flew by and i sadly do
agree it probably is about time to wrap
it up i mean three hour streams are
crazy normally you know podcasts are
only like an hour long so it was it was
a wild ride but i really enjoyed it um
you know i'm down to come back on
whenever whenever you need another guest
you know how to how to get a hold of me
i'm sure we'll we'll discuss the future
episodes behind the scenes regardless
but uh yeah if uh any of you aren't
familiar with my stuff my name's the
vivid kiwi i do breakdowns theories uh
all that sort of stuff on my channel
usually i'll take specific moments from
each new episode and do videos just
solely dedicated to that and then around
the end of the week i'll do a full
episode review i also try to do um
trailer trailer breakdowns usually as
soon as they come out and i can find the
trailer um it's really trying to really
try to bite my lip uh throughout this
whole live stream to not not spoil you
know what's in the teaser but uh i mean
just kind of plug my own stuff i guess
that's that's the most recent video i
have up so uh if if you're interested in
seeing what will happen next week feel
free to go check out that video because
i don't know it was it was a lot of fun
to make there's a lot of uh exciting
things that i talked about in that
episode and uh i think i think when you
watch that video you really tell that my
energy is just at an all-time high
because i really am excited for episode
606 and i i really did like episode 605
so i'm really looking forward to doing
all of these uh in-depth breakdowns on
all of these different moments from the
episode so yeah feel free to uh check me
out thank you guys for all of your
support i really
really enjoyed all the super chats and i
was trying to read uh the regular chat
as much as i could love all the support
and uh yeah this was was really fun
thanks for having me on
yeah and um we'll we'll talk a little
bit before next week i know jim is
coming back next tuesday um so we'll see
i don't know if we can i don't know how
many people
it seems like every time we add a person
it adds time
which yeah it depends on it'll depend on
what the what the uh what the the thing
is but i know he's confirmed and and
we'll definitely have you back again
maybe next week uh maybe the week after
we'll we'll see how
schedules and everything
uh
line up but we'll talk about that
offline
thanks again everyone for coming out
you can find links to his channel and
gill's stuff in the description so go
there and check that stuff out um i only
invite people on who are into this and
are you know i've talked to
personally beforehand so uh you know i
definitely say go check out their stuff
and i'm going to go to my appointment
and i'll say thanks one more time for
coming out and we'll talk to you soon
have a good